I feel like my YouTube is going to get um perma banned soon cuz
I got like broad demonetized yesterday for they didn't even set
a video. >> Then what about the lawsuit right now for showing
some other girl some girls nudes to someone? Anybody can file
a civil lawsuit for any reason. >> Killed by his wife.
She's 12 by the way in brackets which is funny. >> So he
has some like >> which is which is funny guys. Just just
in case you missed it. It's a banger joke. Uh here it's a banger
joke. It's look, it's the joke. And which is funny by the way,
becoming more and more radical as time was passing. Yes, he was
raised in a Republican environment, but he drifted further and
further to the left. So why can't you stand there and admit that
there are radical leftists that want to see people like Charlie
put in the ground?
What we can celebrate, okay, what we can celebrate is
Destiny getting heckled at the UN America tour. Okay, that's
what we could celebrate. Email in March, email in July. Don't
worry about it, bro. Kathy doesn't speak English that well. Okay.
Huh. Okay, hold on. What is >> Right. I just got banned
because of bad empanada. So, >> is that why?
>> Um, so Erdite says she got banned now because of bad
empanada.
>> So,
that's insane. >> Yeah, he made a lot of psychotic post
about me. In fairness, I made a banger joke about him. >> What
did you say? So the loner box said that if Hassan became the
>> Oh god, is she going to explain a joke from Twitter
to this guy? >> President um he would be immediately usurped
by bad empanada and he would bada would throw him in a goolog
and I said and but bad empanada would eventually get by his wife.
She's 12 by the way. >> Guys, welcome to fresher podcast.
Man, this is Money Monday is going to be show. We're going to
talk about one of >> shut up. Shut up, Myin. Wow. Her
get it? Cuz he's like Muslim. Is he Muslim? I actually don't
know if he's Muslim. That was the banger joke, guys. Just in
case you missed it. Okay. She did a totally banger joke about
Muslims being >> killed by his wife. She's 12, by the way,
in brackets. Which is funny. >> Just so he has some like
>> which is which is funny, guys. Just Just in case you
missed it, it's a banger joke here. It's a banger joke. It's
Look, it's the joke and which is funny by the way. The joke.
It was funny by the way. Do you guys Did Soy Pill catch her?
I Soy Pill's not laughing. She just said it was funny.
The [__] do >> they said? And but Bad Aanata
would eventually get by his wife. She's 12, by the way. In brackets,
which is funny. >> So he has some like child. >> No,
he just looks like it. >> I thought he fled. >> Dude,
what?
>> So some child charge thing. No, he just looks like it.
>> Is there some rumor about He did flee Australia. I don't
know why. >> I thought it was for a child related thing,
but >> I don't I have no idea. >> Wait, is that a
Muslim thing?
It's not I So, she just made that up for nothing. Okay. I All
right.
>> Looks like somebody would jeez. Come on. >> What?
Look, >> can you say that as Destiny's business partner?
Can you can you say that as Desty's business partner? He just
looks like it. I feel like you work with the prime suspect in
every child disappearance in Miami. Like
>> it is. Have you seen a meme where it's like you say
it a horrible thing and it bounces off bounces off into someone
who actually looks like bad but doesn't digle kids? >> Like
people in my chat being like, >> "Yeah, they feel bad about."
>> Okay. All right.
So guys, that's the that's a couple of the teasers for UN America
here. All right, so let's go into it. I got a couple timestamps
here. We're going to watch a few of the highlights and just enjoy.
All right, enjoy it. Enjoy it very much.
At Juck, of course you can. She's professional experience. Just
compares be to Destiny and it's the same phenotype apparently.
I haven't done a I haven't done a thorough comparison. Maybe
it is. I I don't really know. Bad Panata looks pretty uh
he looks like a crazy guy to me. Different kind of crazy guy
though. >> Like trimming my beard, man. Leave me
>> So Destiny hops onto the panel a little bit later in
the day. All right,
>> Destiny hops in here after a little bit. We're going
to have to disabout just a little bit, guys. Okay, that's why
we're on kick only. This is going to be some crazy language,
but we go we go a little bit later in the day. Destiny actually
comes in. He goes to get set up. Oh, we weren't even that far
forward. It was only like 10 minutes forward >> because
you for
Excuse me. I'm just going to sit past my word.
>> You guys go. You can >> tell us how many pictures.
>> Sorry. The aerodyite POV on this is uh pretty good.
Okay.
>> Normal normal behavior in the back. >> Oh, your
mic's not on.
>> Make sure
>> it wasn't on. It wasn't on for them. It was on for the
stream. Yeah. >> These guys are laughing. Hey, I noticed
you guys uh like enjoying our heckler. Could I ask you guys about
it?
>> I think it's pretty good. I think it's kind of funny.
It's just interesting to watch for sure. >> What's funny?
>> Oh, no. It's interesting to watch.
>> Is there something funny about them saying that my business
partner kids? Is there something funny about that? You you find
it funny when they when that guy says that my business partner
kids. You think that's funny? But when I I don't know if if you
want if you want funny kid jokes, follow me on Twitter. I had
a banger about bad empanada actually just the whole thing going
>> No what's funny about the guy calling him uh the yeser
>> I don't think that's funny no I'm saying like it's it's
kind of it's crazy to >> okay gotcha gotcha not funny >> no
no you shouldn't say that you should not say that it's crazy
to watch
>> dude these are the turning point kids if you're going
to be conservative okay if you're going to be conservative you're
going to go to conservative political act like uh conservative
political activities you're going to go actually like speak your
your mind as a conservative,
wouldn't you? I don't know. Wouldn't Wouldn't you be the free
speech Chad who indulges in those things? Like, what's the point
being in carrying all those other [__] beliefs if
you're gonna
lose that perk, not caring about I I don't know what I'm trying
I'm trying to weave here. Okay. >> Low blow.
>> Low blow. >> Did you think it was funny though?
>> No, I just thought it was a low blow. >> I don't
believe you for some reason. >> Okay. What did Is this
something that like college kids are are
stuck with now? They just constantly do like weird Tik Tok faces
into the wind. What is this guy doing? Why Why is he making this
face?
>> Yeah. You're pulling like a weird wjack face right now.
So
>> A wjack face.
>> I don't I don't understand what you're saying. That's
not That's not
>> Okay. This guy's This guy won, dude. No, this guy won.
>> Wait, what did he say there? I didn't hear the heckler.
Does this guy know that girl or like other questions? Does he
know this
>> Who? That guy. >> Does he know the other people?
>> He's He's So he's walking around with his wife filming
him trying to rage bait all the liberals to like be mean to him.
>> And then we're like, "Do you want to talk to us?" And
he's like, "No." And then like runs away.
>> Oh boy. Okay. I'm kind of more excited for the stuff
that goes inside when you can actually hear it and when maybe
we could hear like Yeah. any of the debates going on, any of
the [__] going on.
What do we skip past? Little too late point. I'm kind of exhausted,
but I don't know. We'll see. >> Oh, this is uh this is
Destiny talking about his demonetization apparently. >> Little
too late point. I'm kind of exhausted,
but I don't know. We'll see. Um I don't know.
>> I feel like my YouTube is going to get um perma banned
soon cuz I got like broad demonetized yesterday for they didn't
even site a video. So, I don't know. I'll appeal it. We'll see
what happens. But
a little too late point.
Yeah, I think I think they'll win their appeal. I think like
I'll be real, there's a certain kind of like
I feel like Destiny's going to have support inside of YouTube
to get unbanned pretty easily.
Personally, I I think if I had to guess, okay, if I had to bet
on it, I wouldn't bet that that demonetization sticks here. >> Hi,
Destiny. How's it going? >> Hey, pretty good. How you doing?
>> Good. So, I'm a student representing CSU Political Review.
Um, I just wanted to question you about some of your rhetoric
recently following the death of Charlie Kirk. Um, so you've or
not you, but dude, this guy really decided to show up in Charlie
Kirk's suit. That's up. Okay, that show some respect for the
guy. You can't take his suit. You can't take the red tie, the
blue sho, the blue jacket. All right, the Trump suit. Really?
>> At the aftermath of this event, Charlie Kirk has almost
become a martyr for the Red. You think that the of conservatives
and the fear of conservatives to be killed is going to turn down
the temperature of their leaders, but I was just at the vigil
and I'll tell you what, their temperature has only risen. So
why do you think that the temperature is going to go down for
leaders like Donald Trump that you test kind of one weakness
optics? Uh this guy's not an optics. This guy is saying I'm a
right-winger and guess what? The temperature is not going down.
That's insane. There are ways to engage with this. We'll see.
We'll see where he goes. No, I saw you at the plaza speaking
about earlier clearly not turning down their rhetoric at all.
>> Yeah, I mean I don't think the rhetoric is going to
turn down because I don't think Donald Trump has any desire to
turn it down. Um I think the left has been disavowing violence
and calling for a decrease in the rhetoric for like the past
decade. And for some reason, for some reason, Republicans seem
completely and utterly unwilling to do it for everybody that's
saying right now. I welcome you to go look at Joe Biden's Twitter
to see what Kla Harris has said, see what Barack Obama has said,
and then you can go ahead and post me what Donald Trump has said
in response to everything, which is just a call for more violence
basically on the right. So, I understand what you were saying
earlier. Um, you were saying that the left doesn't have a need
to disavow like that should be on the conservatives, but I feel
like >> I think everybody should disavow to be >> Everybody
should disavow. That's why I'm here. That's why I'm speaking
with you. >> that's great. But I But what what about the
president? But what I'm getting at, it's not about the president.
>> Well, the president isn't going to like obviously the
president does disavow Charlie Kirk's,
>> It's not about the leadership. It's about you promoting
this violence, saying that conservatives need to be afraid of
dying at events. That is what I take issue with. >> This
has nothing to do with conservatives. Go ahead.
>> Oh, he's going to he's going to try to m bailey him
and go, "Oh, this doesn't have to do with conservatives dying."
But it's literally the exact thing he said. So violent, violent
conflict for political beliefs in the United States is not good
for anybody. I feel like that fear exists on the left. Nobody
wants to see the violence. For some reason, it feels like the
right feels like they're invincible and that they can go out
and say the craziest things and invite like all of the conflict.
That Donald Trump is still pushing. You can say it. I mean I
mean just watch look at what Donald Trump says. I invite somebody
up here to tell me how Donald Trump has disavowed violence without
blaming Biden or the left when you come up here. No one's going
to have anything to say because he hasn't done it. It's absolutely
insane to me. So I don't know if the feeling is just that the
the right is inviting conflict. They don't think it's a big deal.
They I I I can't tell. I genuinely can't tell.
>> I mean I I think I think the temperature that I'm gathering
and while you know as a conservative I don't follow the >> But
I will say okay this is I don't know how you the thing that seems
weird to me is not even like Destiny's been like a provocator
for a long time as like Z and the America tour. when she comes
out and says how like we totally disavow this, you can't you
can't say that and be taken seriously as a political leader and
have the person you're having headline your tour say the exact
opposite of what you're saying, right? Like say just like have
no concern. You have to have some alignment on messaging, right?
Isn't this the problem with Democrats in general that they don't
have alignment on messaging that they can't get their their issues
through Congress? They can't get their issues like any buy into
their stuff because they're totally disconnected on messaging.
like I I don't know how you do this, how you promote this guy
and say like, "Oh, but I'm also like totally totally nonviolent.
I don't I don't I don't any of this stuff and he's going to go
up and say this." Not that like like I'm sure there are people
who would say like I watched some Vosch speak I watched Vosch
speaking on this a little bit earlier. Vos really hasn't moved
since the last time I saw clips of him in like 2021 2022. He's
like, "Yeah, Republicans are evil. Yeah, we are we do have to
prepare for Civil War, right?" And he's like, "Yeah, Destiny's
based. Destiny's based. Yes, don't don't disavow. Just get your
guns." Like, yeah, we're basically just headed to Civil War,
right? Destiny is totally fallen into alignment with Vosch. So,
there are people who will share that exact same lane with people,
right? Like, like we'll share that same lane with Destiny, but
it's not Z and it's not Aerodite. So, I don't understand how
they can sit here and pretend like, well, no, we're totally disconnected
from this guy. You're not. You're you're literally professionally
affiliated with
>> All right. You don't follow the leader of your party,
the political party. >> You're not my party. I'm a conservative,
but I'm also registered as an independent. And the thing that
I kind of want to
the the the thing that I want to ask you is you need to make
a statement very firmly condemning violence. And when you say
things and you go on Pierce Morgan and you continually say that
the right needs to disavow, so do you. Trying to do this is just
like
is just gay. Um you get optics, but if you go you have to disavow
this right now. You you can't do that. You can't you can't do
this and look cool in any case. Anybody who ever tries to convince
you to do this is trying to convince you to commit like influencer
or like stream.
Okay? You have to come out and say exactly what I tell you to
say will always look to 99% of people watching any stream ever.
It's like a horrible position to take. It's a horrible thing
to say. It's like it never works. Okay? It literally never works
ever. All of us need to. That's the point of this tour for 10
years. The right refuses to do >> It's not about My question
is not about left versus right. My question is about your recent
remarks. That's all I'm trying to get at. >> Well, if you
don't even care what the president has to say on violence, why
do you care what I have to say? I'm not even part of your political
movement. >> I do not care. >> There's an unserious
care. Why do you care what I say? >> I also care what the
president says. My point is that >> I should ask him to
turn it down. >> I also think Destiny that you have a role
in doing this because you represent >> You're wrong. You're
absolutely wrong. >> You don't think so when you have such
a big platform. You know, you're the biggest United States. Not
as big as JD Vance. Not as big as Nancy Mace, not as big as all
these lawmakers, cabinet members, presidents. >> Uh, Destiny
is definitely bigger than Nancy Mace. He doesn't have as much
authority, but I mean, he has more of a voice. People hear what
he says way more than Nancy Mace. That's like not a good comparison
at all. >> Vice presidents, podcasters, alternative media
guys on the right, everybody from the Daily Wire, the abandoned
hit show, all of these guys are saying the left is the enemy.
The radical left Democrats won the causes. They had a whole conspiracy
let out about who the shooter was before they even knew who who
who anything about him at all. So, I'm sorry. Like the idea that
you're up here saying like, "Well, your rhetoric is responsible."
Is a is hold on. How does his bean intake match up, though? He's
brutally in bean intake. Nancy M's bean intake. Bean intakes
per per pound. Bean intakes per minute. I I mean, she's she's
chowing down on beans like nobody else in Congress. All right.
Kyle Kolinsky's got he started calling her out on it. All right.
It's really unacceptable. There's a bean shortage in the United
States and Nancy Mace is directly responsible. >> It's
a joke. I don't believe that your rhetoric is responsible at
all. I'm saying that the promotion of this continual rhetoric
will only feed into the right. This is only feeding into the
people that you are saying to disavow >> To say to let's
get >> I want everybody in this violence feed into the
right. >> I was at the rally. >> No, you >> this
is I think the thing Destiny doesn't understand is like populist
rhetoric can work. This can work, but you never ever discuss
you never talk about like your principles. You basically just
go vibes entirely, right? You don't try to get to the underlying.
You can't be the guy who finds the underlying solution who wants
the truth and a populist. These two things don't match. All of
the people who like you because you find the underlying truth
will be put off by the populist message. All the populist people
who are with you because you're like, "Yeah, that don't disavow
the violence until Trump does it." They should be scared. All
of those people will be put off by you trying to find the truth,
trying to actually like figure things out, right? You're meshing
two things that fundamentally don't mix.
That's the problem he has. He wants to be the populous guy or
he wants to be populist when he's like losing his temper when
he's totally emotionally dregulated like he is right now. But
he also wants to be the guy who's like who studies things, who
knows things. If he wants to commit entirely to being populist,
he needs to stop entertaining anybody who's going to do the optics.
He just says, "Fuck you." No, [__] you. It's all
them. [__] you. It's all them. And that can be the
only answer all the time. Don't try to be the guy who figures
out the underlying truth. >> Cuck me on stage and it lost
me the presidency. This destiny guy let people cuck him in the
bedroom and destroyed his marriage. >> Okay. All right.
Thank you for the vibe. >> When I say I want everybody
in this country to be able to discount violence, how does that
feel? >> When you say that conservatives need to be afraid
of dying at events that turn down I said that everybody should
have a healthy fear of political violence. We shouldn't want
it to happen. >> So then say everybody that's not what
he said. That's not what you That's not what he said. I want
these cons conservatives to be scared is the exact
Just lie. Just lie. Just make things up. Just pretend that nobody
else watched the clip. Hold on. Give me the hutch clip. Give
me the hutch clip right now. Where is this [__] Uh
x. Not this one. Hold on. I need this. I need this clip right
now. Let me find it really quickly. I don't even know if I Oh,
I did tweet it. Hold on. I tweeted it. I'll find it. Two seconds.
I don't tweet that much.
>> There it is. Here it is. We'll just listen to it again.
I shout out the crime statistics.
>> Not not exactly like >> I need you need conservatives
to be afraid of getting killed when they go to events so that
they look to their leadership to turn down the temperature. The
issue is right now
that's not that's not I need everybody to have a healthy fear
of political violence. I need everybody to be a healthy have
a healthy fear of political violence, guys. I just need I need
everyone to have a healthy fear of it because we should all be
scared of it and we should all act better. That's not what you
said. You said you want conservatives to be scared, so they're
You wants conservatives to be scared about getting shot, so they're
terrified when they go to events, so they push Trump to push
to turn down the temperature, right? It's all partisan. It's
all This entire statement is partisan. It's crazy that he'll
just go up there and lie blatantly to people. He'll just He'll
just lie. He'll just say, "That's not what I said." Yes, it is.
When you say that conservatives need to be afraid of dying at
events that turn down I said that everybody should have a healthy
fear of political rights. We should >> That's not He's
just lying. He's just
>> Wanted to happen. >> So then say everybody should
have said >> He said this for decade
but you guys don't hear it. >> Then you're not you're not
connected to
>> I'm not connected to reality. >> You're not connected
to reality. >> Just blatantly gaslighting this guy. Uh
I didn't say that. Uh, you're you're actually disconnected from
reality right now. Are you okay? Are you all right?
>> How many how many BLM writers did Joe Biden pardon?
Exactly. How many J6ers did did Donald Trump pardon? What kind
of a message is it sending to your base to say that you can commit
violence on my behalf to install me as a leader and if you get
caught, I'll I'll pardon you. >> Okay, I'll be real.
Is there security really just could have let this guy in like
the skull bandana in the front row sit there and like that's
I'm sorry that's like incredibly concerning to me. This guy's
like hiding his face. What is he going to do sitting in the front
row over here? I that's a little concern. I don't know. That
seems a little concerning to me. Here's a lot of implicit assumptions
that you're making. You're assuming You're assuming that I support
January 6th. You're assuming that I support
>> Yeah, but you're generalizing me as a part of the Republican
right when I'm standing here. I'm standing I'm standing here
with a with a club and we are trying to promote dialogue here.
That's all I'm concerned about. And all I'm asking you is that
as a conservative where I have faced this fear for, you know,
years where I have also dealt with threats of violence.
That's why I'm here. That's why I'm doing this because I also
don't stand with the demagogues that are calling for violence
against the left as well. >> That's fine. But so if you
say that violence is the thing that worries you, if I were to
go through your Twitter account, is there a single tweet of yours
criticizing the president for his >> I don't use Twitter.
I don't engage in online rhetoric because I think that it's pointless.
>> This is an unserious question. >> This is not
an unserious question whatsoever. I don't need to use Twitter.
>> Um I understand that you like try to make a difference
in the real world and you like run your little club on campus
and you talk about politics, but what's your Twitter profile
look like? Can you show me your Twitter pink slips? What what
radical statements have you made on Twitter? Have you done any
work on Twitter? Have you even done the work to participate right
now? >> To be engaged in politics when I'm part of large
political organizations on campus. I'm engaging with my enemies
in person, not on the screen. That's what
Respect for being here. Good enough.
>> Oh, this guy's a Charlie Kirk true believer. Okay. I
respect you for being here. Good luck. Okay.
He's a true believer. He's like, "I believe rational I believe
discourse and dialogue is the way to save our country." He did
just kind of dominate him, though. So, it's a lot easier to give
that like, "Oh, I I I hope you I wish you good luck." It's a
lot easier to give that when you won.
>> Um, just a quick note, if you're not asking a question,
you can't be in the aisles. We need them clear for like 88 something
something. Safety, safety.
>> Believe me, it's great to meet Destiny. >> Okay,
hold on. Sorry. You need both mics. Okay. Okay. >> I need
both mics. It's a technical issue. Real question here. Sorry,
I hate with the Trump. Believe me, Dusty, you're you're not the
master debater. You never have been, >> quite frankly.
>> Okay, hold on. We just We need a >> Yeah. Yeah.
I'm going to ask a question. Serious question with the the name
of your movement. It was the first thing that I saw. I knew nothing
about your movement. I I watched you on my TV earlier this week.
I thought what you said was pretty intellectual and I enjoyed
what you said. Um why UN America? Because my semantic question
is how do you un something once you have thoroughly done the
deed? No. S seriously, seriously, seriously. Once you have done
the deed, it's like the Virgin Mary is no longer a virgin after
that point. That's just I I just don't I just don't know what's
what's your point with that. >> You're going to have to
ask the people in charge of branding. It's not my name, so I'm
sorry. Yeah, my bad.
>> Why is this [__] shaking like she's on Viveance?
Rude question.
What's wrong with bouncing? Okay. What's wrong with bouncing
something? Some people just like to bounce, man. Why are you
policing?
>> That's fine. >> Any any last one last question
and then we got to move on. >> Do you agree? Do you agree
with that sentiment then? UN America, could you explain what
that means to you? Because with Charlie Kirk and Turning Point,
he said we're going to make a turning point in culture for youth.
For you, what does UN America mean in your words? >> For
me personally, I think that right now we are living in I mean
it's already been demonstrated completely and totally separate
realities at this point to where we can't even agree on what's
happened on either side. And if we have an inability to connect
on even basic facts, I don't know how we have any conversation
to move literally any aspect of the country forward. So for me,
I yeah, I wish that there was better reporting. I wish that conservatives,
you know, weren't so complicit with Donald Trump lying about
literally every single thing that comes out of his mouth. Um
I wish that yeah, a lot of the media environment needs to be
fixed, especially on the conservative side. >> So, how
do you once I cuz my my feeling as an American is like we are
in this position right or left, we have the country. How do we
besides a culture war? And I I don't know if you know um Curtis
Jarvin, he's an obscure figure on the right, and he says there
is no winning a culture war. And even being here, I I applaud
the the debate, but how do we win a culture war like this where
it's constantly, like you said, we can't even agree on the same
facts. So, where do you see this going? How do you want something?
I mean, there's a role for like tons of different people involved.
I mean, it might be advocating for a politician you believe in
at some local level, state level, federal level. It might be
a guy who makes video essays. It might be people that run political
clubs on campuses. I mean, at some point, people in America are
going to have to make like better decisions and decisions with
more integrity about what it means to be involved in politics.
That it's more than just a hobby or a game or that it's more
than just sniping headlines or that it's more >> Wait,
why is he he is he just projecting it himself right now? >> More
than just telling whatever lies the most convenient on your side,
but I mean, absent people willing to do that, >> bro. The
reason everybody's mad at you is because you said conservatives
need to be scared of getting murdered at events. That's why everybody's
mad. So, they pressure Donald Trump. You want to blackmail conservatives
into pressuring Donald Trump to bring down the
>> I mean, it's I guess we just continue to go in the direction
we're going. >> Can I can I keep talking?
>> You can line back up. Okay. >> Thank you. I appreciate
it. Best of
>> Hi. Uh, I wanted to commend you for doing this. Just
getting up in front of people and talking instead of violence
is exactly what we need and exactly what both sides should be
doing. My question was about something you said earlier this
week on the Piers Morgan Show. Um, you said,
which quote is it?" You guys, if you guys didn't want Charlie
shot, then you you should have voted for Trump. You shouldn't
have voted for Trump. You guys Charlie when you voted for Trump.
>> If you wanted Charlie Kirk to be alive, Donald Trump
shouldn't have been president for a second chance. Why would
you say that? And what would you what did you mean by that? Cuz
that >> because I think Donald Trump is constantly using
the most violent and the most extreme rhetoric possible. I don't
understand how you can continually support somebody who, you
know, laughs about people dying in boats in Venezuela, who laughs
about bombing Iran, you know, even though we're supposed to be
the country of no new wars. Um, a guy who like at every opportunity
he has to take a different >> Wait, did Desty disagree
with the bombing of Iran? >> Different path. He continues
to make statements basic. >> He's using the most violent.
Okay, we're we're doing hyperbole, guys. Okay, don't get caught
too hard by the hyperbole, okay? encouraging violence on Fox
and Friends. They asked him twice if he would disavow violence.
And he can't do it without blaming the left or talking about
Joe Biden. Um, who makes jokes about invading other countries,
who calls all Democrats radical leftist lunatics, who plays games
with FEMA, who won't, you know, even have the base in DC, he's
going to call Tim Walls and and, you know, give him some condolences
over the assassinated Minnesota senators. Um, I mean like when
you're voting for this over and over again and you think it's
like epic and based and hilarious and then you know that like
the political violence in this country has been ramping up over
the past like 5 years and nobody is paying attention to it because
anytime it happens on the right on the >> wait is the political
violence like objectively ramping up?
I actually don't know how to quantify that. Is there like a sharp
sharp uptick in violence? I actually like I'm just I'm genuinely
curious cuz I don't I don't actually know. It feels like >> it
feels like it's a clip where it's like randomly happening and
I'm not sure that it's like really related to who's in power.
I'm not totally sure. >> The conservative side, you guys
memory hole it and you meme it away and then you come back to
hope the next one is about a left leading person and it would
talk about that and then here we are. So
>> how about the Buffalo shooter that had 180 page manifesto
and the great replacement theory? Yeah. You don't >> Are
you a big hater of people who who who
proilitize the great replacement theory, Destiny? those people
you think are like scum or terrible shouldn't be interacted with
or you got a problem with the I I didn't think he had that big
a problem with it. I remember this. How about the How about the
two How about the two people that were killed in Minnesota recently
by you know >> it wasn't by a leftist. It was absolutely
the guy told his whole family to register vote for Trump.
>> Go ahead. >> Yeah, there's a school shoot that
just happened in Colorado. Yeah, the whole the whole January
6th event from start to finish the all of
just going to encourage that. Sorry, >> It's going to encourage
it if you just keep talking to the crowd. >> Oh, okay.
Well, that's what we're here >> You mentioned the Buffalo.
There are a such a minuscule fraction of centrists and right-wing
people that are willing to support somebody like that. That is
>> some of those things are on the left, but some of them
are also on the right. I not everybody neither radical is a neither
radical is good. >> But when you go on a when you go on
a show like that and you say, "All right, one of the major two
party there were two candidates. You elected one and because
of that Charlie Kirk was shot. you should have elected my candidate.
That is exactly what it sounds like you're saying. >> You
have to like my other people everything Donald Trump says. I
don't agree with a lot of what he says or what he does. He should
disavow violence. He should do a lot of these things. But going
on there and saying, "Okay, you voted half of the country voted
for this. You have you are the reason Charlie died. You should
have not voted for this side of the party." That's exactly what
it sounds like on national television. I I mean I'm sorry if
that's >> it's not on national television but offensive
but at some point when we grow up we have to realize that politics
is offensive. You're offended. You're upset about it and you
should be but when you vote for people you're voting for very
real things to happen. People getting deported from the country
isn't a joke. Doing terrorists that are destroying parts of our
economy isn't a joke. Yeah. I mean clap away for it. That's it.
I mean that's on you. I mean even you guys as fiances are getting
deported. You guys are you know laughing at people going on about
it. It's absolutely insane. So but I mean as long as you're willing
to >> clap and laugh and joke about it. So, I think there's
like you could say that Trump's like destroying the country.
I agree with that entirely. I just don't know why that means
that you you tie that to Charlie Kirk getting killed,
right? Like I don't think that
uh if Donald Trump if Donald Trump had caught that bullet, okay,
hypothetically, if he had caught that bullet in Pennsylvania
and he he was dead and JD Vance was running the country,
would would the Republican party not still be running the the
they're trying to trans your kids rhetoric? Would that not be
would that not still be the exact line they all run with where
it's all the trans hatred. Charlie Kirk's just as much of a threat
to trans people. This guy's just as radicalized by whatever like
Peter segment were on national television. What? Uh maybe they
were shown clips, but I'm saying it he wasn't saying it on national
television. He was saying it on a YouTube program, right? It's
still it's probably not something worth quibbling over. But yeah,
so I I just don't know. Like I don't think I don't think Trump's
quite as central as people make it seem. Like he is he is the
biggest figure and he is a problem absolutely, but there's like
a schism in the country culturally that is not solved by any
one figure going away. about it, that's fine. But don't be surprised
like when other crazy stuff continues to happen in the country
like it's the direction that you're pushing things. So
one sec. Little stage break. When I get them out, >> wait,
wait, wait. That is actually true. Hold on. He would have had
to go a different way. He would have had to have a heart attack
or something. Yeah, you're right. If uh if he had caught that,
that would not be good. >> Just come a little bit more
forward. We'll just >> caught that bullet.
So, real quick, I just wanted to ask, this is kind of the same
thing as the last one, so I'll try to be brief, but you know,
I saw some comments from you saying that, you know, in regards
to, you know, events like the Charlie Kirk shooting that conservatives
should be afraid to go to such events. Now, this this quote,
please don't interrupt me, good sir. You can talk as much as
you want. Okay. The the the full quote, listen to what I'm saying.
Are we here to talk or are you going to just [__]
meme? If you're going to misquote me, I'm going to correct you,
right? I don't think I think I think Thank you. Yes. Let me speak.
Thank you. What I'm saying is that
sir, I don't make 30 second videos. Let me ask you Jesse Waters.
Okay. Can Can we have Can I have my one oneonone
>> Can I have my one-on-one conversation,
>> Let me have my oneonone conversation. Okay. What I said
was Hold on. Hold on. >> Dude, I literally can't even hear
what the question was. Hold on. I One second. I got a transcript.
So this is what this is. Uh this is what did you mean when you
said conservatives should be afraid to go to events, right? >> Hey,
I want the speaker I want to honor his time. So I need you guys
to just you if you want to talk to Stephen, just come up in the
line, okay? I want to honor the speaker's time. >> All
I'm saying is that everyone should be afraid of political violence.
It's not good. Nobody should. I'm sorry. I was speaking. You
know, it must have been hard to tell cuz you were talking. But
now, all right, settle down. Settle down. I'm not that funny.
Now, >> nobody was laughing. They were clapping. >> Regard
to those comments which I just mentioned. I guess first, how
is that on America? Second, that's seems like a horrible thing
to say. And third, was it worth getting fired from Twitch? >> Oh,
boy. See, this is like to me it's so unfortunate that the Jesse
Waters thing happened cuz everybody's like, "Oh, that's such
an epic troll. He got them." And it's like not about politics
at all. It's not about any of the statements.
>> So, my Twitch ban was three years ago. you're the fell
for that because you've been bothered to fact check anything
like you don't do with any conservative media. Ironically enough,
the thing I was banned from Twitch for had to do with attacking
trans people. So, you know, double irony there. For your other
two questions, I never made that quote, so I have nothing to
respond to. So, what's the next person?
>> Oh, oh, yeah. Then, what about the lawsuit right now
for showing some other girl, some girl's nudes to someone that
>> Listen, anybody can file a civil lawsuit for any reason.
What about the lawsuit where your president was held civily liable
for raping a woman? Seems like you don't care much about lawsuit,
so the next
o uh Okay. Wait, hold on. This guy should have asked if Desu
is found civily liable if he can now be considered like a revenge
for whatever the but he's not going to clap back quick enough.
>> You know, the thing I was I never made that quote, so
I have nothing to respond to. So, what's the next? >> Listen
again. >> Oh. Oh, yeah. >> Then what about the lawsuit
right now for showing some other girl some girls nudes to someone
that you're >> listen? Anybody can file a civil lawsuit
for any reason. What about the lawsuit where your president was
held civily liable for raping a woman? >> Oh, the guy just
asked a question for >> Seems like you don't care much
about that lawsuit. So, the next one question, right? I don't
need this guy. >> Yeah. Go to the next one. Next question.
>> No, go for it. >> Who says I voted for him?
>> I do. >> Hi, Destiny. Thank you for seeing me.
I appreciate it. This is got to be pretty surreal after what
has happened. But my my one question to you is actually evolving
around what you did say on your platform. And my my question
is when you said that conservatives should be afraid, what was
your intended message behind that? Because when I watched you
Hold up, wait one second, please. Because when I watched you
say that, the way that you said that, that doesn't seem like
a good message to spread to >> Sure. So, where did you
see me say that >> It was online. I can't I don't know
if it was Twitch or my stream. Yeah. >> Well, I saw that's
fine. But so, this is part of >> So, why did you say conservatives
should be afraid? I saw the full context. It wasn't Snip. You
said that word for >> Why do you think I said it? >> I
want to ask you. That's why I'm here. >> I'm asking you.
I want to go. >> It is your thought. >> No, he's
he's taking he's taking debate tactics from food shops. Make
no argument. Say nothing. Okay. And then just say steel man me.
Can you steal man me? Don't have any conversation. Can you steal
man me? Can you Can you please steal man me? Can you steal man
why I said conservatives should be afraid? >> I want to
know what you meant. Destiny, you made the statement, not I.
I'm asking for clarity. So tell me, okay, >> for a site
that can have endless interpretation and charity for every single
in
your question, but I just it's a deeply unserious question. >> I'm
trying to answer your question by what about in to Trump? Okay,
I need to go to Trump. So I'm trying to answer your question
by pointing out that Trump exists and the endless serious question
for every unbelievably insane statement that was said on your
side from literally every sing.
What I meant was you don't know what side I am on. I'm asking
you a genuine
Will you answer it then? >> Yeah, I'm answering it right
now when you're talking. You must not have heard me because you
were speaking at the same >> Please tell me. So the answer
is is that everybody in this country should be afraid of political
violence. It's not good when we start each other because of >> This
isn't what he said. This is totally made up. This is like literally
just not at all what he said. He's just going to lie about what
he said, I guess. >> That's a really bad thing. And it
feels like right now the conservative side isn't asking anybody
on their side to tone it down. So it seems like they're not worried
about political violence. That's the issue. You guys have all
this energy for everybody on the left about this political violence
and you have nothing to say to your leader to the leader of your
party. >> What? You didn't answer my question. What was
your intent meaning behind it? No, you said everybody should
everybody should. What was your intention behind it? Why did
you say it? The intention is that people need to realize that
political violence doesn't look good for anybody in this country.
People need to have that understanding. People need to have that
aware. People need to be afraid that like a civil war is not
a fun thing. People each other how you said it. >> Why
are you asking me for my thoughts? Why don't you just fill in
the blanks? Go ahead.
That's right now. Yeah. You go ahead and post it yourself. >> Deeply
unserious. >> Hi. I was just wondering what you would think
what you would think about how if John Lenny was alive. >> The
[__] and think about what just happened and the fact
that we're not doing anything to respect his legacy and the fact
that we're freaking on his >> Wait, John Lennon?
>> He was an activist. >> Well, I hated the Beatles.
I don't have anything to say for
I don't have a strong opinion about John. I'm sorry.
>> Thank you. I'm >> That was bizarre.
>> I can't hold it. It's just easier. >> I like to,
you know.
>> So, what is your name exactly? Who are >> Steven
Bunell.
>> Okay. So, I understand you're trying to get your 50
minutes of fame, but it's
>> It's 15 years, but go ahead. >> Okay. Before I
ask you questions, I understand what kind of person you are.
How many genders are there? >> However many you want there
to be. >> Oh my god. Get this guy out of here. >> How many?
Oh, how many are there? >> I thought it was male and female,
but apparently after today, it's male, female, and snowflake.
So, I guess I'd go with three. >> I bet you high I bet
you have really high estrogen levels, don't you? >> I don't
know why you want to [__] me. Do you have a question
or Jesus Christ, you guys think about trans people more than
the people that Jesus?
>> You got a question for real. I'm going to take it.
>> Do black lives matter?
>> Sure. Why? >> Okay. Thank you. >> Whoa.
Whoa. She silence me.
>> That's what y'all do. I'll silence
True. Who's silencing Jimmy Kimmel just got kicked off ABC?
>> One more question. I'm sorry. I'm safe. >> Charlie
Park's life matter.
>> Charlie Parks [__] life matter. >> Jesus
Christ. >> I'm sorry,
>> Can I just request for this question? Just no heckling
cuz I just want to have like a real conversation here. I'm not
here to attack anyone or they say I'm right or anyone's wrong.
I I'm trying to just bring about a constructive dialogue. I want
to abandon this partisan that is making people homicidal towards
each other. We're not heading in a good direction as we see here.
People are angry. People are I saw what happened last week. It
was it was horrifying. I couldn't believe it. And I saw everyone
mocking his death on his grave. And that was horrible. And then
I saw everyone on the right getting even more pissed off and
and radicalized and angry and hurling slurs at each other say
horrible things back, you know, back and forth. And I've never
seen anything like that in my life. And um uh how do we just
have form that peaceful dialogue? How do we get through this,
bro? Because we're on the verge of a civil war. I wouldn't have
come here otherwise. I'm scared. I came here all the way from
Florida. I want to get through this. I need nobody.
>> I You came from Florida to Colorado to ask Destiny about
how you get through this. The guy who's sitting here being like,
I want conservatives to be afraid. I think you need to re-evaluate
your life goals, your life purpose. I don't know what you're
doing here. This is very bizarre. Is that zip sip? I don't know,
dude. This is just such a weird ramble to go into this. >> He
likes cancer, but I mean like the right has to be willing to
take accountability for things to like >> we all have to
condemn all political violence across the spectrum. >> Nobody
We've been doing that though. The left has been doing that for
the past >> We all have to. Everyone, >> it's not
you can't. It's the the both sides thing just doesn't work anymore.
It it's like a boat rowing with one. The left can row harder
and harder, but we're sort of going to go around in circles until
the right is willing to actually come out and say, "Hey, everybody,
including us, everybody needs to tone it. I'm not even saying
to say it to themselves personally, like everybody has to do
it." Donald Trump cannot condemn violence in this country without
also talking about the radical left and Joe Biden. He can't do
it. >> Agreed. And I wish he would stop that rhetoric.
Um, even though I understand that and you know, there's a lot
of left like radicals and right-wing radicalism. I see it online.
Uh, and the truth is I think that there's like a lot of left
and right-wing fringes, right, that are comprised of like minors
and I think they just get like really like radicalized and they
see the other fringes, right? They see the other side and they
like radicalize each other and they start believing that like
every >> Get this guy off the stage. Get this guy out of
here, dude. Get get him out. Get him out. >> On the right
of their spectrum is like that. And you start getting these like
radicalized kids doing this like we just saw last week like murder
and Charlie Kirk. Bro, I think it's a real conversation that
needs to be had. I just want to >> Yeah. The the problem
is we have to have an honest conversation about it. The reality
is like when when when there was supposedly a threat from Iran
to Trump uh Biden increased his Secret Service detail after the
assassination attempt against Trump which was by a registered
Republican. Joe Biden didn't make it political. He you know he
allotted even more security to Donald Trump and he told everybody
in the United States that needed to calm down. After this last
shooting happened with Charlie Kirk, in like 12 hours, the right-wing
had spun up, including Donald Trump and JD Vance and Nancy Mace
and Steven Crowder and Matt Walsh and every other alternative
median in life has spun up an entire conspiracy theory about
who the guy was before we knew anything about it. Both sides
are not equal here. The right has an inability to like critically
analyze itself. They think that they're righteous in all of their
anger and in all of their fury. And as long as that's like going
to be a driving force, like one side can't force civility. It
has to come from both sides. So until somebody's willing to like
sit down and >> dude, it's like it's not about civility.
This is just he's totally like bastardized. Josiah's entire flow,
right? I'll just say it again. Josiah's whole thing is you can't
be civil with Republicans who refuse to be civil. That's totally
fine. You can engage in the symmetric actions they're willing
to engage in, right? You can do whatever procedural thing you
need to. You can with them uh yeah, in terms of Congress in any
way. You can not be nice to them in terms of media. In terms
of media appearances, you can not be nice to them. You could
ask them difficult questions. You don't have to be kind. You
don't have to be considerate. You don't have to be civil at all.
But that doesn't extend into doing violent action or refusing
to disavow violent action. There's no reason it has to go into
that. In fact, I would say Trump refusing to disavow violent
action is the same thing. You don't have to say, by the way,
you don't have to say, "Oh, well, everybody needs to cool it
down and stop there." You go, "Yeah, obviously the Charlie Kirk
is a tragic thing. Should never have happened. All political
violence is bad, but the people driving political violence are
the people on the right. You can stick to that line the entire
time. And this idea that, oh, but if I say I disavow this violence,
then Trump wins. You're so brain po. You're so mind poison. Like
actually just you're you're ruining everything. You're just like,
you only exist to draw attention to yourself and to ruin other
people's political engagement. You have no positive purpose in
the United States. You just you provide nothing. You you are
just saying I just want to be like Trump. If that's what you
want, then off, right? That's the that's literally the problem
is people who are who are looking at Trump, dude, could you imagine?
At least Destiny's parents are boomers who like Trump because
they've been radicalized. Destiny is going, I want to be like
Trump because that's a calculated decision. That's psychotic.
That's insane. Why the How the do you end up there? It's nuts.
So I
It's baffling to me. I think it the political engage it's just
totally broken. Um, I think this this guy's got a lot of personal
things going on that are clouding his judgment and clouding his
his message. And hopefully more people are just waking up and
seeing it. >> Honest conversation about that. We're just
going to keep that. >> Yeah. No, I I agree. >> That's
right. Charlie Park is on his program talking about Joe Biden
being executed for treason. Like, I'm sorry, but you're delusional
if you think your side has done anything to try to turn down
the violence. It's just not true. >> And that conversation
that you want to have, like I I also want to have. I mean, are
we going to be talking like after this? Like, is there going
to be groups? Like I genuinely just want to have a conversation
about this. Get full context cuz >> I just want to talk
to anybody. >> Truth is, let me just say >> I came
all the way from Florida cuz I can't talk to anybody. >> One
thing it's crazy how like on social media you like one or two.
>> Somebody get this guy in a trans furry Discord stat.
Okay. Msad's got their next agent right here. It's this guy.
This guy's face is going to be on a billboard a year from now.
Okay. >> Rightwing posts, all you see is everything from
the right. And vice versa. Like one or two leftwing posts, all
you see is from the left. And I think that like the mainstream
media, bro, I think that social media, I think it's specifically
designed to just kind of program us to like hate each other and
meet each other's throats and so we don't focus on like the common
enemy at the top, you know? Um, and >> wait,
who's the common enemy at the top? >> I just really, you
know, I don't want any violence, but like this talks of civil
world, this like anger, this wrath I'm seeing, you know, it's
we got to we got to tone it down. We don't we don't want to live
in a blood bath. It's no that's not good for anyone. >> I
mean, I agree 100%. That's all I'm here to to really say. That's
just my main point. And I want us to get through this. I want
us all to get through this as a country. I'm scared. I wouldn't
have come all the way here from Florida if I wasn't so [__]
scared. I've never seen anything like that like on my timeline.
I just I I just couldn't believe it. And um and also I mean,
>> was this you when you were a populist? I was never really
a populist. I thought the populist rhetoric was like I thought
there was a point to it. I thought I thought there was like something
to it. It just is um it's just letting your emotions win. That's
basically what it comes down to, right? letting yourself be suggestible,
letting your emotions, it's just never good. Like never ever
>> Just say I think we need to just stop going after one
another and targeting each other because the truth is when we
start going after each other and cornering each other, we're,
you know, we're kind of forcing like our adversaries to become
more radical, more irrational because now their lives are at
risk. You know what I mean? Now there's like a conflict of interest.
So if you really want to have like an honest conversation about
this and get through this as a nation, I think we need to stop,
you know, piling on each other, calling for people to go to prison.
Like I'm not about that. You know, obviously a lot of people
across the political spectrum sometimes get carried away and
will say things that could imply violence, but like I don't think
we need to go down that road of imprisoning every because that's
just we don't want to go down that road. So, let's just temper.
>> This guy just wants to yap. This guy just decided he
wanted to come and talk on the mic. Get him out of here. Get
the cane out. Yank him off the stage. Get him out of here. >> Everything
down and have a conversation. That's just that's all I want.
>> Yeah. I hope we can all do that. You
>> I'm just going to say it about that. I wanted to understand.
I take it a second. I I'm just ready to Oh, well, I wanted to
say I'm proud to I'm I'm not scared. I'm proud to be an American
and I'm really grateful that you're here to have this conversation.
And I think that you're right. I think that we're living in two
different realities from the right and the left for a long time.
>> I'm not scared. Okay. >> I was on the left and
I've been a registered independent my entire life. And then after
January 6, actually, I became way more conservative and I support
the right and Wait, what? Wait, wait, that's the Oh, no. That's
the opposite direction you should be going in. What the
what? >> January 6, actually, I became way more conservative
and I support the right and
>> the way those the way those fat people all sacrificed
themselves on the altar of Trump. Okay. The way those fat people
walked over there, got heart attacks from being outside for the
first time in a decade. All right. I found that really inspiring.
I got in on the right wing at that point. Okay. I was like, "Okay,
actually I don't want reproductive rights now. Those fat people,
Ashley Babbett, she tried to get through that window, got shot
in the head. That's awesome. I love these guys. I don't want
to be able to have an abortion. Okay? If I get pregnant, I should
be forced to keep it." Awesome. >> In my opinion, in my
opinion, um, looking and listening to what Charlie Kirk had to
say, which I listen to him all the time, um, I don't think he
was spreading any hate at all. I think he was stating the truth
that Jesus Jesus is the way, the truth, and the life. And I I
also feel
I also feel that um Donald Trump did in fact condemn this violence
um inside of his initial address when Charlie Kirk was first
shot and or whenever he was pronounced dead and then he addressed
the nation. He said that there's no room for political violence
on either side. No, certainly. Uh just like as we know, Charlie
Kirk was starting to see the truth and opening his eyes. Um
>> wait, Trump did say that. Nobody's going to care cuz
he does he does point out a couple times that it's like the left
way more than the right. >> We don't support uh Trump and
we do see him as probably compromised. I mean, the majority of
people who supported him do see this, but that doesn't change
the fact that how are we supposed to have civil conversations?
How do you want to un America? somebody asked you that in good
faith and I didn't hear a really good answer from you and I don't
understand how we're living on two different realities cuz I
would love to understand and see the facts that you're seeing.
I just don't see it. Like I just I see more.
You were talking about Camala Harris and you're like how many
people were pardoned from the BLM riots? How much money did Camala
Harris raise in order to get them out of jail? How many of them
weren't even >> prosecuted? What do you think Kla Harris
did in terms of raising money for people? Oh, well, she it was
still on her Twitter. Like, tweeted like one thing saying like,
"Here's a bail fund to donate to." I think I got like 100 >> Well,
no, but but you're sitting here talking about how it's important
for Donald Trump to use his platform to whatever. Listen, but
Camala Harris used hers to get people who were committing violence
out of the jail. So, irregardless, they weren't even getting
prosecuted. So, let's move on from this. >> Please tell
me how we're going to >> Well, yeah. So, number one, a
lot of people did get prosecuted related to BLM rights. Number
one. Number two, there's nothing wrong with a bail fund. If somebody
wants to raise money to bail people out, that's fine. Number
three, if you want to talk about horrific >> someone tell
Loner Box, okay, someone tell Loter Box there's nothing wrong
with a bail fund. You want to raise money to bail people out,
there's nothing wrong with that. I could have sworn that was
the whole thing with Charlie Kirk, right? Charlie Kirk wanted
to bail out the guy the the Nancy Pelosi guy, the guy who hit
Paul Pelosi in the head, right? Aren't Aren't they uh Aren't
they stringing up Charlie Kirk's memory over that one? I feel
like that does say something though if you want to bail someone
out, right? I don't feel like that's meaningless. I think this
is like a good talking point. It's part of the reason Camala
Harris was not a good candidate. By the way, she had some pretty
crazy positions in like 2020 related to bail funds. Charlie Kirk
was literally saying that people should uh get to a bail for
the guy that attacked Paul Pelosi and then it'd be funny to bail
him out of jail and ask him a bunch of questions, which is infinitely
more disgusting than just tweeting a link to a bail fund from
Kla Harris's account. >> Okay, what whatever. If you want
to say that that's worse, that's okay. That's for you to see
it. But how am I supposed to find the facts the way that you
do? Because to me, it seems like you're a byproduct of the liberal
indoctrination that's taking over this nation. >> Well,
I mean, the problem is you'll never see it because most people,
Charlie Kirk concluded, are too scared to have critical conversations
about us. >> he wasn't scared. He literally died to do
so. How dare you? >> College kids.
>> Talking to college kids. >> Who are you talking
to right now? >> Why don't you
>> Didn't Charlie Kirk talk to a lot of people? I feel
like he avoided certain people who are like really bad optics.
I thought he talked to like a lot of people. I thought he he
was about to debate Hassan in not too long, right? I feel like
he just talked he he just wouldn't talk to people who are like
a total optical poison like like Nick, like Destiny.
Am I crazy? Hold on. Let me see. Somebody had a list. Wait, I
got a list here somewhere of the people he's debated
debated at Oxford and Cambridge. Debated Gavin Newsome, Bill
Maher, Hassan [__] Chenk, Sam Cedar. Had an upcoming
debate with Hassan [__] right
So, so like one, he did debate like actual mainstream figures.
You could say that they're not like debaters or something, right?
But then two, you're literally arguing this while copying Charlie
Kirk's exact formula of debating college students. You literally
have like an open college channel that's mostly college students
and or unemployed people who call into you.
I
>> Any concern? College kids are the only people that I
talk to. >> Oh my gosh. This is the same talking point.
Hold on. >> Heckler's in the back. Give me a second. I'm
on a roll here. Give me a second. >> I like the confidence
though. Listen, I'm cooking this guy. Shut up. >> We already
heard these talking points when you were on Piers Morgan. >> We
already heard these talking points. So, why don't you give us
a legitimate answer? How do you want to un America? I'll have
America with you. Let's go. How's it going to happen? >> How
about you have people debate more than just contract college
kids? How about you have conservatives actually step up and accept
debates from people like me, Sam Cedar, from other people in
the media? >> Okay, great. I'm here right now. Let's go.
What? >> Let's set up more events. I'm here right now.
Let's go. >> Yeah, sure. Give me any debater you want in
the world and I will debate them on any topic related. >> Yeah.
With your what about isisms and coming back up with this is the
other side. I haven't heard. >> Unfortunately for Destiny,
he's like actually trying to do this is like a form of populism
right now, right? He is not able to keep himself emotionally
regulated and to interact with other people without like losing
his saying something insanely foul or doing something insanely
foul. Look at his lawsuits. Look at all the allegations against
him. Look at all the crazy he says. Right? everybody else, the
other people who engage in these debates are capable of doing
that. They're capable of working themselves up a hierarchy and
then taking advantage of that hierarchy at the top. He is not
capable of doing that. He's trying to go, it's so the system's
unfair to me. The system doesn't let me say the system doesn't
let me talk about all the time. Like, bro, that's you're you're
putting yourself outside of the political system. That's what
you're doing. You're engaging in populism to try to get debates
with these people. You're trying to get people to harass them
into letting you debate them. They've already decided they don't
want to. They don't like you. They don't like you, bro. No means
no. I understand this is really hard for a lot of DJers and Destiny
particularly to understand, but no means no. Okay, no means no.
I another yet another yet another masterpiece.
Yet another masterpiece from Kyle Kolinsky. I love beans.
Yet another banger from Kyle Kolinsky. This guy can't miss. This
guy is incapable of missing. This Nancy Mace loves beans. Revolutionary.
anything. >> That's That's Nancy Mace. It's a photoshopped
Well, maybe photoshopped Nancy Mace with a big old barrel of
beans. Okay. Oh, whoops. Made that >> Listen, sir. I'm
okay to change my mind, but I haven't heard anything worth it.
How do you want to fix America? >> Go through it. We can
go through January 6 if you want. Donald Trump and his administration
openly said that they were going to circumvent the Electoral
Count Act. They openly said they wanted to break the law. They
fabricated seven different certificates of electors from seven
different states. They had them submit them to Mike Pence to
beg him to vote for Trump to be president instead of the people
who rightfully won. He called every single person to the capital
on January 6th with the hopes of having a violent insurrection,
which he did in the hopes of delaying the electoral count, which
he did for the first time in all of US history. And while he
sat there and watched the capital burn, a man who said that he
couldn't call the DC police there, even though now he's done
it without DC really wanting it, he sat there and he watched
it burn. He tried to take advantage of the circumstances in order
to get the election, you know, >> okay, I'm going to let
this play for a second. Use the bathroom real quick. I'll be
right back. his way and then after all of it failed, after everybody
went to jail, after people were convicted of stuff, including
a sedicious conspiracy, he came into the White House and he pardoned
all of them. I mean, like these are facts that aren't even contested.
All the charging documents are public. The jury decisions are
public. Everything about this is public. There's nothing >> Exactly.
Well, and there is more to that whole story and that's a regurgitation
of everything that's being perpetuated by the media. But if you
look at the facts of that day and the way that everything lines
up, actually, we don't have the full details in story. Those
people were walking through as if it was a White House tour.
I don't I know a bunch of people that were there that day and
it wasn't an insurrection. That's a really bad insurrection if
nobody had a >> Why? It was a successful insurrection.
They delayed the count of the of the vote. They delayed the the
certification of the vote for the first time in US history. That
was a successful delay. What do you mean? They It worked.
>> It was What worked? And >> they managed to delay
the certification of the vote. >> That was not an interruption.
>> They delayed the certification of the vote. That was
the goal for them going there. Now, what else did they protest?
It was January 6th. It was time to >> No, that's not what
they were protesting. They were protesting the efficacy of the
elect of the election in its entirety over
had 62 court cases. He lost every single >> No, they did
not lose every single one. He wasn't seen and the adequate um
details were >> Guys, guys, guys, you don't understand.
If he can prove that Donald Trump
is like an evil lying totally like a constitutionally
on piece of Okay, if he if he's if Donald Trump's a total moral
reprobate, then that proves that he doesn't have to disavow Charlie
Kirk being shot. Why would he have to do that, guys? January
6th happened. Why would he have to disavow Charlie Kirk being
shot? Why? Why would you have to do that? Come on. Don't you
know Trump's really bad? Trump's like super evil. So, uh I guess
that's what happens. Charlie Kirk gets shot. Wow. Wow. >> Actually
brought up and I actually work in cyber and it's and the what
was brought up in that Arizona court is a bunch of baloney and
they adequately had proof that there was malicious uh intention
and it was un uh the logs from that knack should have been able
to be retrieved and they were only deleted from the time it was
supposed to be. If you're not willing to believe the courts,
if you're not willing to believe the J6 committee that was bipartisan,
if you're not willing to believe a number of like independent
investigators, media people that have all looked at like you're
not going to believe anything besides what you see on I don't
know on Breitbart or >> No, sir, I don't agree with you.
I asked >> nobody cared about J6. I think J6 could have
been talked about. I think people focused on the wrong things
and I think that uh J6 is such a [__] show.
I think that elector's plot, if that elector's plot was all people
talked about, I feel like there's a chance people would kind
of get it. But there's a lot of stuff to do with that riot that
like it's just so hard to it's sorry, it's not hard. Um, a lot
of people who have no concern for your country, have no concern
for your electoral process, who have no concern for your country
actually being a democracy will what about that day and the violence
that happened infinitely. It will never be convincing to people
because they will what about that violence like infinitely, right?
I think the fake fake elector is way more convincing, but it's
not what most people think about. So, >> questions and
that's the reason why I'm still open to all of this here and
that's the reason why I'm skeptical and I'm not going to believe
what the mass media is telling me. >> Just the mass media
on the right. You're just talking about
every single right-winger on this issue just randomly. That's
what you want. >> That's not true. That's absolutely not
true. And that's all you got. That's that's your big guns. I'll
pray for you. I really wish you the best. Thank you.
>> so both. Okay. So, first of all, Destiny, I do agree
with you. People do live in two different realities because one
side can tell us that there's only two genders, male and female.
By the way, if you need any better evidence that Charlie Kirk
totally failed in his mission, look at his acolytes debate anybody.
Okay? Look at the [__] they talk about. Look at the
they say it's so they're so brain broken. It's so dis it's so
stupid to watch. Okay? This is the worst. Every time one of these
gets up and repeats the kind of he would say they they honor
his memory and convince me even more that this guy was like >> And
the other side doesn't know how many go. I'm gonna start there.
Quest my question to you is this. If Charlie Kirk was such a
harmful figure to America, then why did his death trigger such
a massive outpouring of support across political lines, even
from people who never agreed with him? And I'm one of those.
There are several issues with Charlie that I disagreed with.
But doesn't that prove that he tapped into something real about
the failures of our system that you are unwilling to
>> No. No. So you here's proof you were unwilling to acknowledge
it. You went on Piers Morgan and said that you wouldn't disavow
his death until the president of the United States did it first.
Why would you care what a man you didn't even vote for have to
say first before you disavow my president? You didn't vote for
>> Hold on a second. Headphones clicking really badly.
Give me a second. Okay. Like unfortunately this is just what's
going to keep coming up, right? There's no reason for you to
require somebody else to say something for you to say something,
right? It's like it flies in the face of is it not like it's
basically like every moral system that exists, right? You're
advocating open. You're openly advocating for immoral behavior
because you don't like the outcomes you're getting with moral
behavior, which I guess you could say, but like then you try
to you try to like wheel it back and like do the M and Bailey
to something that you could really stand behind instead of just
standing on business. So, I don't know. Like when this guy could
stand on business a little bit, it it kind of worked. Now he
like wheels it back to something. He just like lies and says,
"Oh, I didn't say that." I think everybody should have a healthy
fear of political violence. But it's not the [__]
he said. >> Didn't even vote for half before you
He's still my president. I wouldn't want Joe Biden to encourage
violence against people on the right, which he didn't provoke
security clearances or security details for people on the right,
which he didn't. So why can't Donald Trump do the same? >> Oh
god, how did this guy get back in line so quickly?
This who? Dude, they both did the guy behind the black guy. This
guy did two genders, too. How do you get back in line so fast
for me? Supposed to be there for all did. The young lady that
was just up here before me said that right after it happened.
He said, "We need to not have political truth. Radical left Democrats
were the ones >> Well, the one that killed Charlie was
a radical leftist. >> You know that. You have no idea.
>> We do know that. That's what >> radical leftist
with no crazy chat history, with no evidence of
So, you haven't seen any of the evidence that has already come
out that >> I think there's going to be possibly more evidence.
I've seen some stuff, some reports of like more that's going
to come out. There's some pretty DJ that goes in a very specific
direction there. Now, is it proof that he's a radical leftist?
Not necessarily, but
that he was he was he was a man that had become radicalized his
own father stated he became radicalized within the last year
and a half. And he stated that what do you mean? Where did he
become? Where are the laws any radicalized anywhere? Where's
the a single >> look? First of first of all, go look at
Candace Owens. She's already started the investigation. Secondly,
this was this is already public information. His father was the
one that already turned him in and his father stated this was
happening and the what was the guy's name that he's dating? I
forget the guys. Was it Lance? >> Do I recognize this guy?
Was this guy in like a Jubilee Surrounded or something? Is that
where I recognize this guy from? I recognize this guy. I think
he's on Surrounded or some I think he's been on some Surrounded
episodes. >> Twigs, is that it last Twig? He cooperated
with police. That was the man's boyfriend. And he stated that
he noticed that he the title was becoming more and more radical
as time was passing. Yes, he was raised in a Republican environment,
but he drifted further and further to the left. So why can't
you stand there and admit that there are radical leftists that
want to see people like Charlie put in the ground or and by the
way, you know what's so interesting? I these are two different
questions. If you're going to ask me to tell you that there are
radical left people that would do >> okay, people are saying
that he's a part of America is a conservative voice of >> this
country. Of course there are. We've seen them before. I'm not
going to sit here and deny that. That's obviously >> You
would deny that. You admit you admit that there are radical right
people that would then >> absolutely radical white people.
But that's not that is not the point. Destiny, you literally
he said radical right people. Radical right people. Although
if he had said what you heard you that would also be true. Okay.
That would also be >> on one of the largest platforms that
we know of on Piers. >> I said I want to violence and I
want the president of the United. >> You shouldn't have
to wait for a man you didn't vote for. >> When you guys
don't have to have the other side do it. It can't be one side
doing it. Why don't you understand United States gets on the
gets on television and and disavows it the immediately after
it happens? That's not good enough. What exactly do you want
to do? Fox and Friends, they begged him to disavow two separate
times. >> Who begged Trump to do it? Oh, what? Who begged
him to disable? >> I don't know. Whoever the names of the
guys on Fox and Friends are now Charlie Kirk's uh fans want revenge.
What do we do? And >> you know what's so interesting? As
a black man, one thing I noticed about Charlie Kirk's death,
there wasn't rioting in the streets like it was after George
Floyd. That's the one thing that I noticed about Charlie Kirk's
death. Uh, nothing worse. Nothing worse than a pick me against
their own race. Okay,
>> And it's so interesting that you want to cherrypick
and nitpick and use odd examples that benefit you, but you deliberately
want to have blind vision to see that the radical left ideology
that has been influencing this country.
>> Dude, if if Charlie Kirk if you found out that sniper
was CIA and they killed him for some reason, you don't think
there'd be some riots? You find out that guy's like CIA,
right? the the shooter. Feel like there'd be some riots if you
found out the state literally killed Charlie Kirk. Be a little
wild. No. Would there might be some riots? There might be some
problems.
>> Why did the DOJ remove from their website the study
on on radical politically inspired violence over the past decade?
Why do you take that? >> I have no You don't know anything
about that. I have no knowledge of how I don't know anything
about what you're talking about. I don't know. Of course you
don't. Because I didn't follow that. What do you think about
the Buffalo shooter that 180 page manifesto with the great replacement
theory that went shot and live streamed to some black people?
>> I think that that's wrong, Destiny. I think that's wrong.
>> Why can't the president say this? >> He already
said it, but he didn't say it enough. Why is it that in the Oval
Office when somebody asked him, they said they said when you
guys were having this day of remembrance for Charlie Kirk, the
flag uh Dean Fon passed out, why nothing about any of the lawmakers
in Minnesota that were shot? >> And he said, I don't know
anything about that. I didn't hear anything about that. How is
that possible? >> What do you mean how is that possible?
>> How is this possible? I didn't know anything about that.
>> You didn't know anything about it. That's the whole
point. That's the problem. You don't know what he doesn't tell
you to know about. He tells you to care about illegal and trans
people. You guys are here talking about girl all day. Like, of
course. What do you mean? Destiny. I had three genders. There
are like in your bedrooms thinking about this all day long. It's
crazy to me. >> I'm going to I'm going to say this. It
amazes me. It absolutely amazes me the state of delusion that
the left that the far right the far leftists live in. You can't
even admit that what happened to Kirk wouldn't you literally
state I'm going to say this. going to be done. You literally
stated that Charlie Kirk would not have been assassinated if
Trump wouldn't have been elected to a second term. If you don't
think that's violent language, then I don't even know that what
the point is in >> Is it violent language when Charlie
Kirk said, "I think that Biden should be executed for treason."
>> He never said that. That's okay. Yeah, you conveniently
don't know anything when the right is is rather.
>> Destiny will tell people that direct quotes him verbatim
are lies and you won't know the verbatim for other people. Pretty
sure Charlie Kirk said death sentence, right? death, the death
sentence, something like that. You did talk about public Charlie
Kirk was pretty insane. But I'm just saying that like there's
there's like a a possible defensive framing of the Charlie Kirk
death penalty. Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Yeah. It's
like there's some defensive framing of that. There is nothing
for for what's Destiny's been saying at all.
>> I can't help. >> Oh, this guy's going to be cringe
again. This is going to be cringe. >> I'm going to ask
you questions. Okay. Is that okay with you? That's >> yeah,
whatever you want. >> What are your thoughts on transgenders?
>> I don't think about transgenders. >> Do you think
>> Do you think transgenders should be able to own guns?
>> Yeah, I guess. Yeah, second amendment right. Yeah, >> you
guess it's a second amendment right. >> Why do they keep
on shooting [__] schools then? >> Well, how
they aren't the most they? Whatever the [__] you
want to call it
from owning guns. >> Do you think that being >> I
actually think you need to qualify TRT. Hey, this guy looks like
he's on some gear. Okay, TRT. Uh, anywhere you you push your
hormones outside of their natural range, okay, you count as a
trans person. You can't have a gun. All right, you're if you're
emotionally disregulated because of your hormones, you're a trans
person. You get qualified as a trans person, you don't get to
own a gun. Okay, you get to choose between having your muscles
or owning a gun. Pick one.
Okay, this is this is gross. >> There's a mental illness.
>> I I don't have an opinion on this right now. Do you
think >> Do you think most school shooters were white men?
>> It's all part of the narrative, dude. >> It's
all part of the narrative and you know it. >> Go ahead,
preach. We're interest. Go >> They said that the school
the guy that shot Charlie was a Republican. >> Can you
answer trans people are such a >> I just noticed this.
Shack it up. Yeah. He's got like a really flamboyant way of speaking
for like a for like a who's somebody who's trying to look masculine.
He's got a very very flamboyant way of speaking. Right. >> Effective
assassins. Why would we kick them all out of the military? looking
at this one right here. I want to give this thing a gun. >> Dude,
get the [__] out of here. >> Okay, that's uh
that's rude. That's just rude, man. >> Get this [__]
>> That's not very nice. >> Out of here. Are you
serious? >> Why are you pointing out people in the audience?
You're bullying people. Are you serious?
>> Bully me. I'm up here. Okay. Make fun of me. All right.
>> What's up? Not so Aerodite. >> Hi. What's up,
Stephen? >> Hey, what's up, man? >> Um, I I have
noticed uh as people are talking, you've got a lot of caricatures.
You think they get their information from certain echo chambers.
You think everyone here has a certain voting pattern or party
affiliation. I just want you to know that I was a lifelong Democrat.
I was raised by Democrats cuz apparently that matters. Um, and
I I knocked my knuckles bloody for for Democratic candidates
all throughout my teens and early 20s um before I eventually
came to be where I am now. What I found is that I've actually
read read and digested a lot more information from across the
spectrum than a lot of the people uh that have started to recently
call me names. But here's my point. Uh
>> I'm like I'm like really smart. Okay, I'm just going
to Guys, listen. I was like a Democrat when I was like dumb and
I didn't know anything. Then I read a lot of books and then I'm
really smart now and now I'm a Republican actually. Well, he
didn't actually say that. He said now he's getting called names.
So, we actually don't know. Maybe he's just a really cool centrist.
Okay. In school, we were all taught that are bad, right? Fascism
is the ultimate evil and we should do anything. >> Oh,
get this guy off the stage. Get him off the stage.
Demon spawn. These Democrats are demon spawn. They harvest adrenochrome
from babies. From babies.
These people have to go. They're demons. They sound They smell
like sulfur. Okay. Like, dude, are we really are we serious right
now? Are we serious? Like this whole Oh, you can't call us fascist.
You can't call us fascists. That's that's that's calling for
violence against us. Shut the up >> to stop fascism for
by any means necessary. Uh a lot of us internalized that message
and around 2016 I started to see that message becoming weaponized
against uh other people within this country. It turned internal.
It started with punching. I remember the distinction very clearly.
I remember looking at some of my friends who used to agree with
me about things like free
>> Your head cannon is so gay. Run ahead wreck. You know
that this is a thing. You know, it's a thing mainstream Republicans
talk about how Democrats are they they enabled the Epstein cabal.
They're all they're in a ring. They're running a country from
the country. Okay. This is like a thing I've heard constantly
from all kinds of populist Republicans. It's all over the populist
right. You guys ran an entire election off of it. There's just
a whole there's a whole thing. Yeah. Demon rats are so diet nose.
Okay. Yes. There's a whole You guys won an election off of this.
Okay. You guys got the guy who tried to overthrow your government
elected again off of they're trying to transfer kids and demon
rats want to like eat your babies. That's that's how you won
an election.
I don't know. I don't know why we're pretending that isn't the
case. Okay, you guys had more effective messaging, but I guarantee
you there's way more violence inspired by that sentiment than
there is from the fascist and having them explain to me why it
was a why it was valid to punch,
etc. And I can see a very clear chain up to where we are today,
even if you don't. So, here's my question. Uh, Stephen, what
is
like in the historical sense or in the current what do you >> what
is to you today in America because I've heard you use that term
a lot. What do you mean?
I don't think the only person I usually use about is in regards
to like Sam Hayek who's like >> I usually just use the
term fascist which is what an authoritarian. >> What is
a fascist to you? >> Sure. An authoritarian ultra nationalist
basically dictatorish person. I mean usually it's going to be
a list of policies or behaviors that I do. that the people disagreeing
with you here tonight are fascists. >> Uh, probably not.
But most of them seem to support a fascist in office right now.
So, but I mean like we we can have differences in political beliefs
just like how the Republicans spent all of Obama's presidency
calling him a communist, right? Coming out of the the the Cold
War and the Red Scare and everything else like there is >> and
I appreciated her video recently disavowing the communists that
have infiltrated your party. Um, but that's not my point here.
What does Bella Chowo mean to you? What is what >> this
guy the way you know that this guy has read a lot that he has
figured out his political ideals that he's like figured out his
political messaging is that he is a big time not so aerodyite
enjoyer. Okay, that's how you know this guy's intelligent. That's
how you know he's got a good head on his shoulders. He's like
this not soite person, they're really inspiring me in a political
sense. They're really inspiring to me. That's how you know, man.
He's he's got it all figured out. He's he's assued destiny entirely.
He's on airate, the true political leader of the new American
left. All right. >> What is Bella Chowo? Bella Chowo. Bella
Chowo Chow Chow. >> Uh, I think it was a song in a video
game Far Cry 6 and it's some TV show that was popularized recently.
>> Okay. Now you're in >> It's No, it's a anti-fascist
song from is it Italy? I think it's Italy, right? Obviously the
language is Italian, but I think it was Italy fighting >> intentionally
lying and you know the answer to that question. So, thank you.
You know what Bella is? Uh and and so does everybody here. >> 22-year-old
Mormon white kid, I think, was radicalized in six months by his
gay roommate, actually. That's >> what does what does Hey,
fascist catch mean to you. >> It's a reference to a Hell
Divers 2 video game. >> Oh, it's about a video game, right?
It has no connection to or or Punch a Nazi or any of those is
a secret fascist. We just for some reason haven't uncovered any
evidence for it whatsoever despite the fact that we have his
Discord account, his text messages with friends, and nothing
else has been leaked to us to show it besides writings on the
bullets, which also all happen to coordinate uh or correlate
to video games and and media references. But >> Got it.
Well, thank you. Uh I if this is the quality of your intellect,
I think I should start streaming. >> Oh, the Hey Fascist
catch thing isn't in Hell Divers. Wait, hold on. Zezy, is is
Hey Fascist Catch not in Hell Divers? I thought it was. People
have been saying it. I know the the arrow combination is from
Hell Divers, bro. No, it isn't.
Um, it's that's a quote in the game. Some people are saying it's
a quote from the game. Some people are saying it's not a quote
from the game. The the arrow combo is definitely from the game.
The arrow code. Okay.
>> I guess I can get pretty rich doing it. Thank you.
>> So, here's the funny thing. Okay. Why did Destiny get
that wrong? Cuz I know I got that wrong. I read an article and
got it wrong like two days ago. Why did he get it wrong? Did
he read the same article or was he peeping the stream again.
I I just >> Hi. Uh so I just want to start off with just
a discussion about political violence in general or uh polarization
between these uh two I guess parties. Um so first I want to acknowledge
that Charlie Kirk's assassination was political violence. Um
and I am very leftwing. I'm on the left. I have a lot of left-wing
friends. Most of my friends are left. Um, but I have to admit
that after this happened, I did see calls for more violence.
I saw uh jokes and I think that's wrong. I think that's also
political violence and it's polarizing. And I also have to admit
the things that Charlie Kirk has said have hurt my community,
too. I mean, after he was shot, the first thought I had was,
I'm scared for my trans community members. There's probably going
to be backlash against them. And some of the stuff he has said
has, I think, caused some backlash. Um, there's a reason that
the United States of America ranks third. >> How' this
normal person end up here? Get her out of here. She's she You
don't want no part of this. Get the Get out of >> And trans
feministicide. That's murders of trans women. There's a reason
that our country accounts for 70% of feministicides in the devel
or in the most uh wealthy countries in our nation. That's the
women because they are women. There's a reason that we have a
missing and murdered indigenous women's.
>> No way. Tom Bronson. Tom Bronson literally said it sounds
like she's about to do a land acknowledgement. She's like working
her way up to it. >> Women because they are women. There's
a reason that we have a missing and murdered indigenous women's
crisis. Our indigenous women are missing and murdered at alarming
rates. There's a reason that black people keep getting shot by
our police again and again and again. There's a reason that we
have homeless people dying on our streets. There's a reason that
we have kids dying in our schools. This is political violence.
What I also want to say is
I've heard you debate with these people with um our community
members. All of us are members of this community and all I've
heard is just further polarization of saying no, it's it's you
on the right causing this. It's your leader. I don't care who
you know our leaders are because they don't care about us. If
they cared about us, we would not be having our women. We would
not be having our community members dying on the street. We would
not all be working our asses off and not able to pay our families
to have food. We would not we would not all be working our asses
off and not be able to afford health care. None of these people,
you know, care about us. So, how can we all agree on something?
Who cares what they think up there? Who cares what our politicians
think? What's something that we all can agree on as a nation
to just, you know, [__] them. Let's get together
and what can we work on together?
>> Okay. Before Dusty answers, guys. Okay. Yeah, she says
she took a while. Took a while to get there. But there's a question
finally. Before we get there, guys, if you like the content,
go ahead, follow me on every platform. Join the Discord. discord.gg/jsdk.
And if you really like the content, throw a couple bucks my way,
okay? You can add more time to the stream. We are, what are we?
We had 20 bucks from earlier. 25. We're like six subs away from
another two hours on the stream. We had a couple big donos like
ear. Not big. We had a couple donos early on for some TTS messages.
So, we're about six subs away from two more hours on the stream.
Guys, get your donations in now. You can sub on kick. You can
give subs on kick. You sub on Twitch. You can give Twitch primers.
Okay, here's the here's the Twitch URL if you got Twitch primers
you want to throw in. All right, throw whatever you can in the
pot. Uh we also have kicks now. We have kicks. There are You
can go on kick. You can click that little shop at the bottom
of the chat. Okay, you can buy kicks. Kicks are about 100 per
$1. All right, you throw your kicks in. You can pay for the stream
just the same way as anything else. All right, so you guys buy
some kicks, donate some subs. Uh, there's TTS links. Exclamation
boy donate in the chat. You get your TTS message read on stream.
Exclamation boy donate. There's Kickbot. There's Streamlabs.
All right. So, donate, donate, donate,
get the money in. Add some more time to the stream. All right.
Thank you guys. Thank you for all the support. Appreciate it.
And let's continue on. So, she just asked basically at the very
end at the very end of saying this is all political violence.
We have all these problems. >> Agree on something. Who
cares what they think up there? Who cares what our politicians
think? What's something that we all can agree on as a nation
to just, you know, [__] them, let's get together
and what can we work on together?
>> In the United States of America, every individual is
allotted a single vote and that is an awesome responsibility
that I feel like for some reason a lot of the country has neglected
lately. The idea that both sides are the same in terms of policy
for helping the average person is just not true. Kla Harris had
an idea related to tax credits for children. You can laugh. You
don't have any kids. That's fine. But for people that need the
money, like the stuff matters, right? When Biden was president,
we had an extended child tax credit that went away under conservatives.
Um when uh when Biden was president, you know, we weren't, you
know, pushing to renew all of the Trump tax cuts for wealthy
people, which Trump did. And now apparently the deficit that
was supposed to be a big deal doesn't matter anymore. All of
the help is going to wealthier people. All of the help is going
to businesses. All of the help is going to bailing out his friends.
When we tried to get a singlepayer option, or at least like a
public option uh in the United States, it wasn't Democrats that
stood against that. It was the Republicans. the ACA that we got,
we only got that much of it because the Democrats were willing
to push for it. So, if your take is just, and I understand, especially
for young people who haven't interfaced much, I guess, with the
world outside of school, but like I mean, even for school loans
and stuff, like it's not like Democrats are the ones trying to
get rid of those. It's it's Republicans that are trying to fight
against higher >> No, it's it's both, man. Like, it's both.
And I know it's something that we can agree on. You talked about
politicians. So, I'll answer myself. Something that >> I
was going to say he kind of just flipped it into like partisanship,
which he was like, can we do something? Can we agree on something
bipartisan? And he's like, "No, these people." >> We all
can agree on together is that we love our nation. You got to
love something before you can fix it. We love like these beautiful
mountains out here in Colorado or rivers, you know, everything.
We love it. So, whatever. He's not going to answer, but I'll
>> If you don't have a strong opinion on it, then don't
vote.
>> Bro, why? Why, dude? Why is he so inhuman? I just don't
get it. He's like so
She's literally like that. That's actually the thing that like
is his worst optical like defeats all seem to come from. Like
he's interacting with a normal person. You just see like the
discrepancy. There's just a massive discrepancy. She's just like,
"Hey, can you give me like anything we could all come together
on?" And he's like, "No, these people suck." She's like, "Well,
I think we all love the country." And he was like, "Well, if
you don't have a strong opinion, don't vote. I I don't I don't
know how that works. I don't know how that works at all, but
okay. chop
>> I feel like you you could just go, you know what, you're
right. We do love the country. We need to come together as people
who do love the country. I would say you could even partisan
up that one. Hey, I don't think Republicans love the country.
I actually think they hate the country. I think that's why they're
on the Constitution of the country and destroying all of our
norms that keep this country great. Right. You could you could
easily do that, but I don't know. You don't vote. I guess don't
vote. Ending it on a Mr. Girl quote is kind of crazy. Okay, hold
on. Young, black, and frustrated. Look, bro, I get it. But I
got some advice for you, homie. So check it. Don't vote. Nah,
that's old people. That's white people. If you want some life
improvement, don't drink the Kool-Aid. Just drink some Kool-Aid.
Stay home on Tuesday. Play some 2K.
Cuz they don't respect your color of skin. Yeah. Plus, I heard
you have to take a swim test and they put you >> subtle
racism for Max. You hate to see it. Okay, continue.
I voted 10 times for Biden. All of my legal names.
>> There it is. Y >> I'm not.
Um so since kind of the 1970s, 1980s, kind of through the 1990s,
we've seen this de-industrialization in the United States, and
it's led to the complete downturn and downfall of a lot of places,
especially in the Midwest. And I think you know both political
parties
um have kind of abandoned a lot of these people especially in
place like Gary Indiana. So my question is what do you think
the government or politicians should do to help support these
communities cuz I think they're just kind of forgotten about
completely but they're Americans. They're hard workers who lost
their jobs and I think these are people struggling from opioid
abuse, drug addiction, alcoholism, all this stuff and I think
they they just need help. Are you familiar with the um Obama's
quote uh they uh they cling to their religion and their guns?
You heard that one before? >> Uh I have. Yes, sir. >> You
have any idea what the context of that quote is? >> I am
not sir. No. >> So in 2008, Obama was in a it was a closed
door conversation he was having with donors. And one of the things
that came up was Obama had felt like over the past decades um
since NAFTA basically that there was this hollowing out of the
industrial base in kind of the middle class in the Midwest especially
um and kind of the rust belt. And he said that administration
after administration had ignored basically the needs of these
people that they didn't have jobs that they could work anymore.
They didn't have things that they could contribute to and feel
proud of. that these places that were these like massive manufacturing
centers of cars, you know, places like Detroit, um, were hollowed
out and they had nothing. And he said that in that environment,
it shouldn't surprise people that they, you know, cling to religion
and their guns and and become anti-immigrant or whatever else
because it feels like the entire world has left them behind.
Um, Obama was, and I feel like the Democrats have been willing
to have that conversation. Coming into office, McConnell said
his goal was to make Democrat a one-term president. Uh, and McConnell
said that was his goal for Obama was to make him a one-term president.
And you've seen over and over again, uh, when Trump was in office
in term one, there was like nothing in terms of legislation.
Um, there was like the I think they got the tax cuts and then
I think some first step back for crime, but not like nothing
really, didn't he? They wanted to do they almost had the Obamacare
repealment, right? They almost repealed Obamacare. Old uh, big
shiny Tumor McCain came in. Okay, he shut that [__]
down. Have you ever seen some of the photo dude the photoshops
of John McCain are gross. >> An infrastructure bill. They
couldn't do it. They talked about repeal and replace the Affordable
Care Act. They couldn't do it. Uh there was just nothing. Biden
comes in and aside from the American Rescue Plan, which fills
the coffers of every single, you know, state and local government
budget. Um you know, we we had the we had the infrastructure
act, we had the inflation reduction act. We had so much legislation
that poured so much money into so many different projects. And
now that Trump is back, we have nothing again. He's trying to
uh defund some of the investments that were made for that. He's
trying to take credit for other parts. And now he's tariffed,
you know, every single country in the world, which is just going
to hurt again like the middle class. It's causing a rise in inflation,
an increase in unemployment at the same time, and a decrease
in our in our GDP, the overall amount of stuff we're making.
All I'm trying to say, I know it's like boring numbers, but the
this problem making progress in our country from the governmental
front will never be fixed when it feels like one side treats
politics as a reality TV show that's just here to get clicks
over and over again for it. Like I feel like the Democratic party,
I can point to legislation. I can point to policies. I can point
to positions. I can point to things they've done to measurably
improve what's going on in this country. And then on the Republican
side, it's all just like a big joke. It's just like >> I
basically just agree with a bunch of this stuff that like the
Republicans broadly even before Trump were not committed to like
actually getting policy passed. We're not committed to like bipartisansship
or making the country better. It seemed like they were starting
to break down into like we're just going to be obstructionist
every time we're here and then we're going to help donors every
time we're like actually in power. That's pretty much like how
I saw it the whole time. That's I think how most people saw it.
I think Trump came in after that. But I >> Yeah, I don't
renaming the Department of Defense, the Department of War, videos
of Nome Christy in front of immigration cages. Like, how is Alligator
Alcatraz supposed to help manufacturing in the rust belt? Or,
you know, how is another bombing of Iran for Israel supposed
to help us, you know, make more cars or bring back some kind
of decency to the middle class? Like, I don't know. I just don't
see I don't know why people keep equating the same sides on both
of these >> Listen, I agree. And >> you say this
evil Johnny Bravo, but the Tea Party movement are supposed to
be libertarians. They're supposed to be like radically more liberal,
more um freedom based than anybody else. They're supposed to
be libertarians. They're supposed to be like people who are about
personal liberty. And they're enabling the guy who is by far
increasing the power and increasing the reach of the executive
more than anybody ever.
Right? He's absolutely he's massively upping the amount of power
the executive branch has in government. He's like the opposite
of what those people stand for. You can say he fell in their
lap, but
he's the person who's working against any of their principled
interests. >> I think I was talking about how I feel I
agree there's, you know, it's it may lean more towards Republicans.
Absolutely. I'm not, you know, like a Republican or anything,
but I'm more curious about what you think. I'm not I I understand
the policies of the Democrats. I understand the policies or ideas
of the Republicans. I'm curious what you think about this issue.
I don't want, frankly, I don't want to hear about Trump or Biden.
I understand their policies. I support some of the stuff behind
it. Absolutely. But I want to hear your position, please. That's
all I'm asking for respect. >> I mean, in regards specifically
to
>> Yeah. I think one of the issues, I mean, depending on
the conversation, one of the issues is we have to understand
that there are certain ways that the economy is modernizing and
it will probably never take a step back. Like even if we bring
back manufacturing now, like those jobs are going to engineers
or people, you know, manning robots or whatever. So the the problem
is that like the tempting thing to say on the Democratic side
is there needs to be some kind of like welfare redistribution
or whatever the people that are in these cities in order to you
know help them who can't work uh because they can't keep up with
whatever the current economy is. But the reality is nobody really
wants that right like if you have a job and you create things
you don't want to just be a welfare person city who does nothing
like you want some kind of job or something to work at. Um like
I feel like there could be like it has to be some kind of investment
in some combination of like education or job training. It has
to be geared towards like a certain group of people but it has
to be like an honest conversation. It can't just be you know
like I think for a while liberals where you know like oh everybody
has to go learn to code like it's probably not going to happen.
But also on the other side, >> the honest conversation
was like, "It's not going to hurt your job prospects." People
would rather just have their jobs and and the GDP of the globe
be lower. That's what people would rather, right? I don't know.
Like people just want to just be, well, we're just going to tear
up the entire world until we manufacture things at home again.
Like that's not going to happen either. Even if we do manufacture
things here, it's going to be robots making them. So, um, yeah,
it would be some complicated probably combination of of of retraining
and education and investment in like certain regions of the country,
but that would be the way forward. Yeah. >> Yeah. Well,
I appreciate your answer and I'd also like to say quickly I agree
that I don't think uh manufacturing can come back. I think we're
decades past that. So, yeah. Thank you very much. >> Thank
you. >> Thanks for the question. >> Want cheap knickknacks?
I mean, everybody wants cheap knick-knacks and that's why you're
like kind of in a country like America cuz the rest of the country
is going to vote to get rid of your [__] But then
you also just have to be empathetic to the fact that none of
those like that entire manufacturing base is going to be really
difficult for Democrats to ever win again, right? After getting
totally hollowed out. like they're just it's going to be super
hard for Democrats to ever win in those places again consistently.
>> Have a good day.
>> Both. Okay. Hey, so we talked on stream last week and
I think you can tell I'm progressive. Anything you're about to
say about Trump like we both agree on that you're preaching to
the choir. So I don't think that your disavowel is going to change
his rhetoric. That's very obvious. What I'm curious is what your
end goal is. if you're trying to hold up a mirror to the Trump
administration. Are you trying to advocate that our politicians
have the same rhetoric of not disavowing violence? Because the
way I see this, uh, you have a very influential, uh, position.
You've got an audience of people who are willing to hear you.
And when we were on stream together, it sounded to me like you
said, Republicans should be more afraid. You can tell these people
it was out of context. Maybe I misinterpreted you, but if I'm
charitable to you and I hear that, what do you think the millions
of people who hear you are going to see? because I see that just
as dangerous as Hassan promoting a Houthi who you rail >> Yeah,
I don't think it's a serious question. I don't I think that >> I
think you're just so signaling at me actually. And listen, you
wouldn't even stand on business. You wouldn't even let me You
wouldn't stand on business for the good of the country. Okay.
You're just a [__] You're a [__] who
would abandon me like everybody else >> the because I I
I don't believe that you could have that feeling and then watch
Donald Trump go on air
and you're preaching to the choir. Please, can you do it without
talking about Donald Trump? I think everything you're about to
say about Trump clear a million times. I think I just without
violence a million times. >> Okay. But why are you not
doing it now? >> What? I have I have before. I have the
I will not go into
what's your what's your goal? Is it for clicks? Is it for
this and have some semblance of sanity?
>> Uh
this is the unfortunate thing is as soon as he's up against anybody
who does any amount of this stuff, they'll just keep pointing
out like you're dodging, you're dodging, you're dodging. I don't
care about Trump. I don't care about Trump. I don't care about
Trump. He loaded it in right off the bat, right? Makes Dest's
whatabouts to Trump look >> Carved out then allow conservatives
to hijack another shooting that if it turns out they don't get
the woogie wool trans, you know, manifesto that they really want
that they're just going to memory. Where do you stand on Soy
Pill? Soy Pill is like kind of I've heard him be like really
on panels. I'm sure he like is decent. He's got like a big channel.
He had like a big channel before he started doing politics streams,
I think. Like I'm sure he's an intelligent guy in some ways.
I've I've just sort of made make really bad arguments before.
>> Pull this one into non-existence like have every other
instance of conservative violence. >> Okay, so why not
just do that? >> I would rather fight here and I would
rather have for the few people that are left with some semblance
of sanity watch a bunch of people come up to me and say, "Destiny,
you YouTube influencer, I care more about your opinion on political
>> but I'm not saying you understand. I'm not saying that
that's also not what anyone else is saying. Literally nobody
else is saying you have a bigger responsibility to dispow violence
than Trump." Not a single person saying it. That's just totally
made up. That's like a fabrication. So you could be an unhinger
care about your influence. I care about your influence. I care
the way that if I can take you and I can be charitable to you
and I can still say, "Wo, this is unhinged. This person might
be saying something incredibly dangerous. This person has millions
of people. This person is becoming the conservative straw man
on Pierce Morgan, on CNN, and all these places that someone in
his audience might take the wrong message from that and do something
bad with that." So >> honestly, that shouldn't even be
your primary concern, so Pill. Your primary concern should be
every single Republican that exists uses this guy as a foil to
to campaign on. They say this is the left. This is who you're
fighting against. Right? He is he is now basically like who's
a good fo he's like Keeles, right? In so many ways. He's just
the person they can all hold up and go look at this loser. Look
at this. We don't want to be dude. You want you want to vote
for these guys. No, he didn't say more Cy. He said that's a problem.
He said you're becoming the Republic. But that should be the
bigger issue to Soy Pill. It's not realistically uh DJs are losers.
They're probably not going after anybody, right? I don't really
I'm not really that concerned. It it contributes to a broader
issue, but it's not like somebody in his audience is going to
hear him speak and go someone. I don't think Okay, that's me
knocking on wood. Okay, I I just knocked on wood with that. I
don't think but a as a real tangible consequence now the this
guy is being used to push the Republican narrative all over the
internet and he is absolutely like a useful idiot to them. Okay,
way more than Hassan, way more than Vosch, way more than all
these people. All right, he is the useful idiot at this point
said to get kicked off with ABC. >> I do. Why are you bringing
up things that you and I agree on? >> That it doesn't matter
what it does. No, it matters what you say to your audience. It
absolutely matters. Do you think that it's okay for Hassan to
say I support the Hooi terrorists? >> Not only do I not
think it's okay to say that, you know, Elon Musk and everybody
else posting tweets about the gun tweet that he made. You know
that tweet, do you know where that post came from? Came from
my subreddit. So, yeah, of course. I've been calling up political
violence for as long as >> came from my Twitter. >> A
streamer. Obviously, I don't want to get killed. >> So,
you think everyone who sees you people who don't know about you
are going to see you on these bigger mainstream shows and be
like, "Oh, well, I saw this Destiny clip from seven years ago.
It's okay that he's saying it now cuz I know what his position
was then." >> seven years ago, >> what? whatever
either last week. >> How could he say Hassan is bad but
have that position? It's a
>> it's a dance said that political violence should not
happen in this country. I've said it again, >> right? So,
is this just for you? Are you saying our politicians should adopt
this or are you just using it as a way >> saying that people
on the right need to adopt this? >> Obviously, but what
do what how do you think this is going to happen by your position?
What do you think is going to happen when you
reasonable people on the center were going, "Hey, that is kind
of weird that Donald Trump isn't calling for violence to come
down to this country." It was kind of strange. I don't >> Wait,
do you think you could maybe get that message to the center people
a little more easily if you weren't also saying Republicans should
be in fear of their life outside?
Maybe. Maybe. Just maybe. Maybe. Was it a Was it actually a requirement
for you to say they need to be scared for their lives? I don't
think so. >> Don't really feel comfortable with my >> The
requirement is he needs his attention. Okay. He needs his attention
and that's what it that's what it actually fulfills. It gets
him his attention. The point that political violence is bad.
You can you can make that point with or without saying that I
want Republicans scared for their lives >> and saying,
"Hey, all of us need to calm >> What reality do you think
these people don't notice that and that you're highlighting it
by not condoning violence that people on that other side can't
do it? I don't care anymore. I rather play video games. >> Okay.
Well, my problem is that you
>> the actual four-year-old tantrum. If you don't let me
have my way, I'm going to flip the table over. You don't let
me have my way. I'm just going to flip the table over. I'm going
to go play video games. I'm going to go play video games right
now. in this world is well everyone's this online internet tuned
in person meanwhile finally you're on these bigger platforms
saying this thing and this is the first
why am I on the >> because they like the inflammatory rhetoric
that's why >> you think I said you think I said to be like
guys there's another one we all got to come >> okay so
he's just that's that's an interesting confession right there
>> around disavow
talking about it they just be going to >> no but I think
a bunch of people watching you who are fans of you have stuck
around through all the you've done are going to be like oh now
he's saying that maybe violence isn't so bad. Maybe conservatives
should be afraid and might take the wrong message from that.
>> I think I watch my community enough to know what their
feelings are on political violence. >> This is the exact
opposite of the argument you've made in the past saying you're
responsible for the behavior of
If my community was turning into a community political violence,
I would be >> Well, it's only been a couple weeks, so I
hope we don't have to say years as a firefighter sitting and
it's been 10 >> You didn't advocate for political violence
then. You didn't refuse to disavow. You were making fun of people,
which you and I can both agree. We can mock things for political
violence right now. Why would I ask? >> You're refusing
to condemn it on screen. You're making people that I detest look
better than you and have the moral high ground. That's how
>> uh so Pier's a content genius. He knows what he's getting.
Bringing Destiny on. Well, Piers is a content genius who has
a total political leaning, right? Piers wants to make right-wingers
and Republicans look good and he uses Destiny for that purpose.
And Destiny absolutely fulfills that purpose. Destiny makes his
money, he gets his views, he gets his adrenaline rush from having
all the attention on him. Piers gets his money, his views, and
pushes his political opinion. and left-leaning people lose. You
all lose.
That's the That's the bargain that's being made. Okay. And the
the funniest part about this is people who seriously are like
liberals. They want Democrats to win in the United States. Give
this money. They give him money to them.
Incredible stuff. And it looks >> then be better. Have
some integrity
integity. I'm asking you constantly when these guys are over
here clapping for >> Why do I have to [__]
clean up your [__] Because you're not responsible
enough to just say one thing. >> Donald Trump was [__]
a woman after >> you are preaching to the choir. You know
I think all of this already
part of my community and I need to All right, whatever. Type
one in the deep
>> Wait, I just noticed this. Someone tell me what's going
on with this thumbnail. Trump now declares anti-fascism to be
terrorism. Trump's angri begin.
Trump's angri begin.
What? What's going on here?
What is this? Just like AI gone wrong. This guy just like threw
it up there. Hey, Wolfie. Yeah, I don't know. Autodubbed.
>> I need to hold both. Okay, cool.
>> Okay. Hey, really fast. I just want to kind of address
everybody. I'm so glad that you guys are all here. However, I
do want to be able to just have a discussion with this man that
unfortunately I do not know, >> Turning Point USA without
all of the background noise and everybody interfering and trying
to get their thoughts in. If you have a thought, I think you
should come join this line and speak your truth. But do not be
trying to join everybody else's conversation. Okay. The first
thing I want to ask you about is earlier I heard you say something.
Unfortunately, it was very loud in here so I couldn't hear at
all. Um about Charlie Kirk and how he was addressing college
age students and that was who he was talking to. Um I mean if
you could like elaborate I guess on what you said cuz I didn't
get >> Yeah. There's a lot of conser the vast majority
of the conservative movement right now is absolutely scared to
death of having any kind of actual critical challenging conversation.
So most of them have set up shop just like making a living out
of debating college kids. Ben Shapiro did this for a while. Charlie
Kirk was doing this. Um Steven Crowder did it with the change
my mind stuff. But that that's basically exclusively the people
that they would have challenging conversations with. >> So
I want to ask you
>> he knows that's not true. Yeah. I again I'll just point
out repeatedly that these people did have other challenging conversations.
They just didn't want to have them with Destiny. They just don't
like Destiny,
right? It's not that they won't debate anybody who's challenging.
They just don't want to debate one guy
>> Why are you so against debating with college kids? We
are the future of America in 30 years. We No. Everybody, please
no.
We are the future. We will be running this country in 30 years
whether you like it or not. Unfortunately, that is the truth.
>> Why don't they just get rid of Aerodite and get a mic
stand? Um
>> I I don't know. I I >> It is better to educate
us now while we are 18 to 25 because our public school system
has not
to be clear. I mean, I'm here debating college. I have no problem
with people that do it. I just don't like it when people pretend
like they're open to debate when the only thing they'll do is
debating, you know, less prepared younger people. That's my issue
is pretend. I think having Yeah. Incredible conversation with
a college campus is a great idea. Yeah, >> I respect that.
Yeah. Um, my other one is, you know, unfortunately I don't know
much about you and I'm not on social media, very rarely at least,
so I have not seen it. However, I have heard several things about
you said something about conservatives should be afraid to come
to movements or things like this and I kind of want to ask you
the context and what the full thing said was because I haven't
seen it. >> Yeah. So,
>> as somebody who goes to events and does events like
this, um when I
think Yeah. When I when I saw Charlie chat, this is an incredibly
horrifying event. Um my you know, the first instinct is seeing
a colleague getting is always an incredibly uh like it's just
I Yeah, I actually don't know why she's
standing there blocking the person who's actually supposed to
be on the screen. Like, it's actually ruining the shot. Like,
the whole point of this is you get clips of the person talking
to the student, right? Isn't that the whole Isn't that the goal?
It's hard to explain like the the very weird feeling, the very
not good feeling you get watching at number one. And then number
two, there's like obviously um this fear of, you know, well,
is this going to happen to me or somebody else that I know um
who, you know, close friend or whatever else at an event. Um
these are like horrifying things to me. Uh when I see a leader
go on stage and stoke the flames, it makes it feel to me like
the other side is not taking the violence seriously, like it's
just a joke or a game. And the statement that I made, if you
watch the full statement, I say this exactly right, that like
people need to be afraid of the possibility of us going to civil
war. And right now it feels like conservatives just have no fear
of political violence because again more people are interested
in shouting at me to disavow some, you know. >> Does she
have like a monitor that's showing how well she can overlap like
basically cover this person up? She like not want these people
on stream. She doesn't want the camera to catch whatever shooter
and have no interest in telling Donald Trump to issue statements
saying all of us need to calm it down. If Biden was the president
right now, if Biden was the president right now and I, you know,
saw the same shooting happen. and Biden came on TV and he was
like, "These radical MAGAs are out here stirring up trouble all
the time like bro you need to chill out. You're going to give
me is absolutely insane. It's unhinged." Um, and the fact that
all of the Republicans are applauding along and saying things
like civil war and stuff and it's like it feels like yeah, like
there's no fear there. Like people need to be afraid of of of
civil war, of any kind of fight like this. It's not good. It's
not fun. It's not romantic or like it is in movies. And I just
I feel like that fear doesn't exist at all on the right right
now. Not saying that people need to kill people on the right
or people need to go and commit violence. It's right. is saying
that all of us >> again again he wants them to feel politically
pressured by the violence to go and push push Trump to do it.
That's he just keeps making up a whole bunch of things that he
didn't say. >> Have a healthy fear of what like a violent
political future looks like. And I think for the most part we've
all lived a privileged enough life to not see that as much in
the United States. Although we've been tending a lot more in
that direction recently.
>> Yeah. I mean I do I do agree with that. the Republicans
that unfortunately are in the public eye, right? There is a very
select group of people who are in the public eye who are constantly
under microscope being watched. That is what you see. And I do
kind of agree that they do not seem afraid for our country.
uh Dingolingus says he's just explaining what he said. Okay,
Dingus, I think you should be in real life. Okay. And when I
say that, what I mean is everybody should have a healthy fear
and respect of violence and and do what they can to prevent it.
That's actually what I meant when I said you should be raped
in real life. It's almost like, hey, you should actually say
the things that you mean and not leave like that much insane
room for interpretation. Like like obviously, sorry, not even
you shouldn't take away all the room for interpretation. Say
something that means the entire like an entirely different thing
than what you just said and they go, "Yeah, here's the
Like it's obvious what he was saying
and you can't just explain away what you said already. It doesn't
make any sense. It's just categorically not what you're saying
and you've had every chance to take it back and you just doubled
and tripled down on it. Right? You didn't go, "Oh, no, no. It's
actually just about everybody having this is like this is like
focus group tested explanations that he's come up with a week
later." as you know a young 21-year-old woman who is I don't
I hate going into this part but you know tall blonde thin I am
usually the number one stereotype to go into trafficking and
is just straight facts and it is a ter terrifying thought that
I already now conceal carry because I'm scared to go anywhere
alone I am always watching my surroundings
but now I'm also have to be afraid because of my political beliefs
And I don't think that that is what you meant by what you said.
At least I hope not. However, I do I unfortunately think that
is how it came across. >> I mean, I think it's come across
on programs where the goal is to not do journalism anymore, but
to take like a >> No, it's Oh my god, dude. Imagine Imagine
being a kind of loser who would go and run defense for this sort
of like lying happening in the in the open. Okay, imagine I just
It's >> minute clip and then to get as mad as possible.
I think it was proof earlier. Again, I'd like to think that at
some point in the past like like two years ago, three years ago,
he was like better at this and it wasn't as embarrassing. It
wasn't as like blatant, as obvious as on its face the whole time.
>> Came up and referenced something that's made the rounds
on all the mainstream media, national and international, that
I got banned from Twitch recently. That's not true. That was
3 years ago. I tweeted out cuz I knew everybody would take the
bait on it. It seems like journalists no longer have any type
of actual uh desire to dig through and figure out like what is
a person saying or what's going on. He got to go on Piers Morgan
and he didn't back off of the position. He literally never backed
off of the position. He had an open mic to go and speak. His
he had worse quotes the second time he had a chance to clarify
this. How in the world is he actually coming up here and going
uh the only way you could think that I I want conservatives to
be scared for their lives is if uh you're you're getting that
information from people who aren't committed to journalism.
The [__] you talking about, dude? this particular
uh statement. Instead, it's just to play 30 secondond clips to
get everybody hyped up. When you say that there's only a select
few conservatives in the public eye, I think it's like intentional.
I don't think that it's just random that Donald Trump has, you
know, begged on Fox and Friends to disavow violence and tell
everybody to turn it down and he won't do it. Um I I think that's
just an intentional choice. Like when when Biden was the leader
of the country, it doesn't seem like he had the same problem
of not being able to disavow violence and not being able to build
bridges with people. You've seen the legislation he passed. Um,
yeah, I just I wish that the right I guess like had a greater
fear of political violence and it wasn't all just a big game
or a big joke to them. That's that's my feeling on it. >> Yeah,
I mean, yeah, I do agree. And unfortunately, I think that is
a huge part of mainstream media these days. And they have done
it over and over to Charlie Kirk as well as several others. I
mean, they've done it to you, they've done it to him of pulling
5-second clips without showing the entire thing of what was said.
So, the one last thing I want to say is I kind of want to address
you guys again. I think that I don't care what your political
beliefs are, your religious beliefs. I think a lot of you do
kind of need to wake up and realize that your president is not
the most wonderful thing. I am a Trump supporter, but every single
president has their thoughts. Vote for who is the best man for
country, not who is the best man in the house.
You know what? I'm going to take the high this one time. I'm
going to take the high ground. I'm not going to make a comment
on the way. I'll just let that
>> I'm fine. >> I'm fine. >> I have a quick
question for you. What happened on May 7th, 2019? >> I
I don't know what happened. >> Um in on May 7th, 2019,
I was at school in seventh grade. And >> what? No way.
Wait, something else had to have happened. Hold on. That was
So I have to I'll be right back. Just give me two seconds. I'm
backing it up. Like I'll be right back. >> Who is the best
man at house?
>> I have a quick question for you. What happened on May
7th, 2019? >> I I don't know what happened. >> Um
in on May 7th, 2019, I was at school in 7th grade and two shooters
came into the school, opened fire.
>> one Alec McKini, who is a trans male, I'm pretty sure,
broke into his dad's safe with an axe to steal his dad's gun
to then go into the school. And so my question for you is earlier
you said that you believe that trans people should have guns
but he didn't use he didn't have access to a gun so he took it
illegally
making gun making it un well making him unable to go through
a background check and how do you feel we can address that?
I have no idea that's a I mean how do you address people who
get a hold of guns illegally? I mean, I I think that there are
things that you can do, but like it feels like we can't have
any conversation about getting to any kind of gun safety thing
in the United States because people >> is he saying it
doesn't matter if you take the guns away from the trans people.
The trans people are still going to be violent anyway. Is that
what he's going to argue? Or I feel like that's what he's about
to argue. Is that I think that's feel like it infringes on their
rights and it also kind of hampers your ability to use a firearm
self-defense. But like the idea of if you have children in the
household, either some kind of tax credit or maybe even some
kind of legal obligation to like have a gun safe or something
where weapons are kept. >> Sorry, just to be clear, he's
he said this person was trans, but they couldn't even own a gun,
so they stole one illegally. So, I feel like he's just arguing
that trans people are violent and going to kill people anyway.
>> Yeah. So, I mean, like I don't know how you can get
I don't know if you can legislate against like like events like
that. I'm not sure. I I don't know what the I don't know. Yeah.
I'm not sure. What do you Do you have an idea or? >> Well,
definitely better mental health support because he tried getting
mental health support. He went through all the steps. Uh he was
working through it and then
he started becoming violent, rude. He was being mean to people
in the halls. And then one day near the very end of the semester
when he was a junior, he convinced Deon Ericson
to go in and Kendrick Castillo who without him I would not be
alive today. Why would you start a clap off of that?
Who the [__] did that? That was like a prank, >> Yeah.
I mean, I Yeah, I wish I had I wish I had a better answer, but
I mean, there might be some This feels so tasteless. I don't
mean it like this, but like unironically, there are some rights
that you have in the country that there are costs for. And I
mean, like it's there's a >> Charlie Kirk quot saying,
you know, related to like the Second Amendment, like there are
some costs that you pay if we want to have guns available in
the United States. There's going to be like a cost associated
unfortunately with um firearms being available here. I think
that at some point you're gonna have to make um a decision about
like what rights you want and what cost you're willing to pay
for them. Um and yeah, right now in the United States, as long
as the Second Amendment exists, it seems like we there's some
trade-off we have to accept for gun violence. Obviously, I'm
going to agree that we should have more mental health support
and everything too. Um it just >> that's just objectively
true and it's not like a own on Charlie Kirk got shot for that
quote, by the requires funding, political will, and I yeah, I'm
not sure just cuz I don't know the very the specifics of what
kind of mental this guy see out um if there would have been a
way to catch something like that early. I know for instance like
the um the black guy that stabbed the Ukrainian American woman
on that bus, like that dude was I think probably mentally out
there and I think people knew about it, but it seems like there
was no support. >> He was released 14 times. >> Yeah.
Yeah. But I mean he was also in prison for 5 years like at one
point so people knew he was crazy but there was no support for
that. Unfortunately, it seems like if you're an adult and you
have issues related to psychosis or, you know, schizophrenia
or whatever else, there's just no support for you. They just
kind of cast you out on the street until you either somebody
or yourself, basically. Yeah. Which I think is tragic in this
country.
>> I agree with that. Thank you. >> Thanks for the
question.
>> Okay guys, we got an hour left on the stream, so we're
back to shill once again. Okay, guys. If you like the content,
go ahead, follow on every platform. Hop in the Discord,
If you want to add some more time to the stream and show your
support in a monetary fashion, you can donate through kick uh
kickbot. You can donate through Streamlabs. You can donate kicks,
you can sub on kick, you give subs on kick. All right, we got
an hour left on the stream. And yeah, any any sub or any support
is appreciated. Love you guys. We have received a ton of support
over the past couple months and you know, I appreciate everything.
Every penny, every kick, every single kick is super appreciated.
Love you guys. Thank you very much. help fight future perspective
homelessness by donating and adding more time to the stream.
Thank you very much. >> Nice to meet you. Uh wanted to
thank you for doing this. Uh I know a lot of people towards the
left don't ever end up coming out uh publicly uh speaking like
you. So I want to thank you for that. Um it's more of a question
that I have for you and what is your take on Jesus Christ and
uh the New Testament?
>> I'm a hardcore atheist so I don't believe in any of
it.
>> Can you tell me why?
>> Um I don't see any strong evidence for the existence
of God.
>> Sorry, did that just fall off? >> Okay. Um can
you back your back up uh your statement on that though? Like
why though on >> Well, I feel like the ownus is on the
other side to prove some kind of >> Sorry. I I feel like
the onus is on the other side to make an affirmative claim, right?
And I don't see any strong evidence to believe in higher power.
So I don't >> Can I ask you a personal question though?
Have you read the New Testament? >> Um the entirety of
it? No. But um I mean >> just the gospels and we can >> yeah
we did I went to Catholic school for 12 years. So just
>> um so
>> the there is a lot of a lot of evidence
>> oh French toast mafia with the five gifted that is we
are $3 away guys. $3 or 300 kicks or one sub away from another
two hours on the stream. Thank you very much French toast Mafia.
Appreciate it dude. >> Up especially the New Testament.
Um, there are over five 5,800 Greek manuscripts or pieces of
manuscripts all agreeing to an infatismal degree.
Um, have you ever done your research uh in regarding that? Um,
or have you just pushed it away? >> Uh, my biblical scholarship
is not that great anymore, but I mean like I remember studying
like the like I think what is it the cube source or whatever
for Matthew, Mark, and
>> Oh, hamster with 500 kicks. Thank you very much, Hamster.
Guys, we hit the we hit the mark. That's two more hours on the
stream, which is awesome because there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that I want to do after this. So, I really was not looking
forward to ending the stream in in 55 minutes. So, thank you
guys so much for donating. Appreciate all the support. >> Let's
continue. >> Whatever. Like a long time ago. I like >> Oh,
wait. Macho, thank you very much for the gifted sub as well.
Appreciate it, man. Appreciate it. >> A little bit. Whatever
I learned in school, but not past that now. But I don't know
if I'm going to be researched into becoming religious right now.
>> Okay. Um, will you ever try to look into that? Um, you
know, uh, just to try to so we can at least try to stay, um,
uh, honest and do your research on that type of stuff. >> I
feel like there's a million other things that are more pertinent
right now in my life to research, but I also feel like there's
like a hundred other religions out there to research, too. So,
I don't know if I have the time to go through all of them. Uh,
if I can ask, with uh Charlie Kirk's assassination, um, doesn't
that kind of scare you that that could actually happen to you
and where you're going to end up after? >> Yeah, but I
mean, who's to say I could end up in the, you know, one hell
versus another versus another afterlife versus reincarnation
versus whatever else? I feel like I'd have to spend the rest
of my life reading through religious manuscripts to figure out
which one is the best one to follow. >> Okay. I will definitely
say you should definitely uh read the Gospels. Um,
>> I'll take it in consideration. Um, I want to say one
thing that Jesus is the way, the truth, and the life. No one
comes to the father except through. >> How's it going?
>> Doing okay. >> I just don't I just weird coming
up for ask political questions. That's all. >> So, uh,
my question is less about political violence, more about what's
happening post the political violence that just occurred. Um,
so on October 8th, uh, for CE >> Yo, Macho, thank you for
another gifted sub. Thank you. Thank you. political violence
has just occurred. Um, so on October 8th, uh, four CEOs have
been called to testify in front of Congress. Uh, Discord, Twitch,
uh, Steam, I'm forgetting the other one off the top of my head,
Reddit. Thank you. Um, and I'm wondering one, what's your stance
on that considering, uh, your view? You've been deplatformed
before. And, uh, also, well, first I guess what's your view on
that? I mean, it depends on like what you're looking at, but
I think that there's probably an unacceptable amount of on some
platforms like an open call sometimes it feels like to violence.
I feel like it's gotten pretty insane, especially on platforms
like Twitch. I think that there are >> There's no way.
There's no way. There's no way. Come on, man. >> Pretty
insane statements made all the time um by a lot of people, but
but I feel like we kind of follow right now the leadership in
the United States. I feel like Trump has kind of set the tone
on where a lot of those conversations are, unfortunately. So
it's hard to come down real >> dude. Hassan Hassan is so
bad. Have you guys thought about how Hassan is bad?
God. Hassan sucks >> on some platform. >> [__]
Hassan >> when I >> Why did Hassan have to go up
on that roof and help this guy sight in a Charlie Kirkan
>> like the leadership in the US itself, you know, echoes
a lot of the same sentiments, but but I mean in general, I think
it's I think it's not good where a lot of the social media platforms
are. Do you think this is like the >> By the way, I'll
just remind you guys, okay, Hassan's message travels way more
via Twitter, via YouTube, than it does via Twitch. Twitch, he
doesn't even get paid advertisement, okay? He just gets his subs
off of Twitch. Twitch is just like basically a middleman between
Hassan and his audience. Twitch just takes money from him, okay?
Twitch is containing Hassan. Twitch is objectively containing
Hassan's message right now. Do not break the dam. Don't [__]
with Twitch. Twitch is doing fantastic work to suppress Hassan's
message. If a son ever realized how big he would how much bigger
he would be if he was on YouTube, we would be okay.
Dan Clansancy. Okay, I need the I need the damn meme again. But
it's Dan Clansancy. He's holding back Hassan. And he's holding
back Asan. He's the thing preventing communism from running America.
Okay. Government actually caring about deplatforming. Or do you
think I mean I'm going to be honest. Your community uh your podcast
host Dan Saltman has been involved in mass letter campaigns to
people like Richie Torres to get people deplatformed. And I'm
obviously referring to Hassan. Uh I agree with you on some things.
I agree with Hassan on some things. I'm kind of in the middle
on that progressive end. Uh however, I do feel like there's been
some content creators uh Asmin Gold, H3H3, all those kind of
uh who have all been involved in this push to deplatform people
and I feel like it's now coming back to bite you in the butt.
For example, I mean your name is being mentioned in congressional
hearings now. I'm just wondering, do you feel any responsibility
for that? I think there's a huge difference between deplatforming
somebody by pressuring a platform to take action on something
versus whoops versus like the FCC uh and Donald Trump pressuring
organizations to do things. >> We agree on that for sure.
>> Um yeah, I mean I I think people have a right to have
their voices heard on things people have deplatformed.
>> I will not disavow violence until destiny does. >> Okay.
Thank you Gunther for the app. you know whether I agree or disagree.
Uh sometimes I mean it is what it is but um I think it's >> suddenly
we're in we're in uh total deadlock guys. Total deadlock. Trump
won't disavow until Desty does. Desty won't disavow until Trump
does. Guess America just gets to burn.
>> Only there was an adult in the room. >> I think
it's fundamentally a different conversation than what we saw
happened just recently with Kimmel and the entirety of the Conservative
party supporting it. I think is a is a very scary thing.
>> Wait, but what about it's like the the letterw writing
campaign? It's like trying to get Congress to censor this guy
for objectively some of the same kinds of speech. >> Um
yeah, but but I mean like like there are some things that people
>> dude you can't you can't get away with this. Come on,
man. You you let your computer you let your community be used
to try to get Hassan taken off the internet for the same kind
of rhetoric that you do. Like very very similar
and it's ironic that it's come back to bite you. Okay. It's just
funny. >> Think they have like an absolutist position on
but their position is a lot more malleable. They just haven't
seen it like tested yet. Like all of us agree in some level of
deplatforming, right? Like if some guy were to go live on a YouTube
stream and he was just abusing dogs all day just like you know
punching him in the head. I think everybody like well this guy
should probably be banned. Like like there's going to be some
level we're all like well this is probably not okay. Um you know
like watching Hassan you know clap and chair with his chat when
hies are hijacking ship. By the way, Dan went to uh Dan went
to Congress, but not just that. Dan went to like stop anti-semitism
other places. Like they were doxing people and like they were
going crazy. They went nuts in the ocean and saying that they're
based in awesome. I think it's an insanely unhinged thing to
watch on a on a media platform, especially
>> uh drama 101. We're literally joking and laughing. I
understand Drew, you have like violent autism, but we're just
joking. We don't actually think Donald Trump and Destiny are
on the same level. We we actually expect more of the president.
Uh unfortunately, the rest of your country doesn't. Okay, Americans
are they voted for Donald Trump. But we do expect him to disavow
violence. He is a [__] And if you base your morality
off of Donald Trump, your country will burn. Your country will
not exist in 10 years. If your entire country the same level
of morals as Donald Trump, you would be
the world would end. Okay.
By their own rules, they say you can't champion terrorist violence.
So yeah, I mean there's going to be some level of >> you
explain the specifics of Dan going to Congress. Did he dox people
in a public hearing? No, no, no, no, no. I'm talking about like
the stop anti-semitism [__] doxing people and then
uh his doxing of like the Hassan's editor and and then what doxing
some of the snark people and going to Congress was through letter
writing and stuff like talking to Richie Torres, that kind of
[__] It's not like totally out out of this world.
It's like not unacceptable. It's um
it is like trying to use the power of the people to to push them
to do hearings on stuff. But I think the goal is to like pressure
the private company, right? You're trying to pressure the private
company by putting like the political spotlight on them. Uh it's
just done in like a legal way. And obviously it's much worse
when the president is doing it themselves, right? When the actual
administration's doing it, it's horrible.
Uh anyway, yeah, here's the thing, Ethan Klein. I actually agree
with this. Okay, Kathy, that I think people are like, "Oh no,
Destiny got banned because or he he lost his monetization because
of like um pressure from the the administration." It's like I
don't know that that guy violates the toos all the time. That
guy's got a ton of toos violations that haven't been got that
haven't gotten caught that if somebody went and lined up all
of those in a document and sent it to YouTube, I think he would
be in a lot of trouble,
right? You cannot dox. You cannot use platforms that you link
on YouTube to dox. You cannot do so many things that he does
and he just does all of them out in the open. If Ethan Ralph
can't have a YouTube, why can Destiny have a or monetize YouTube?
Why can Destiny? Just doesn't make any sense. like obviously
disagreement that people should be allowed to have across social
media platforms, but I think it's gotten really extreme on a
lot of them right >> So, you mentioned the Kimmel thing.
Um, so I mean that just happened. Uh, the SEC is obviously being
weaponized for censorship purposes. I mean, it's also kind of
like Kiss the Ring and will allow you to do mergers, all that
stuff going on behind the scenes. Uh, where do you see this going?
Uh, do you see it being weaponized? >> This is uh this
is actually this guy's asking good questions. This is actually
a big deal, right? It's not like Kiss the Ring necessarily. It's
like
>> it's uh like an indirect ask essentially when you when
you are when you suck Trump's okay there's Trump >> Trump
goes to a glory hole. Okay, Trump there's a White House glory
hole and Trump sticks his dick in there and depending on if you
suck it or not you might get favorable action from the White
House. Okay, most of the time let's say you do. Well, it turns
out that a bunch of CEOs and have lined up at that glory hole
and that is actually bad. Okay. He shouldn't be doing favors
for these people and they're getting like illegal favors like
he's he is allowing people to go. So the the concern right now
is that this what is it the Sinclair
I don't know if it's Sinclair it's like Nextstar and Tegnar are
trying to merge right and that merger is going to have like is
probably going to reach like over a monopoly cap on I I think
like own TV stations or control TV stations in the United States
right I think that's the issue and they're hoping that the FCC
will look the other way because of they're doing like social
signaling they're doing for Donald Trump and that cannot be allowed
to stand right that can't be the way things work. You can't just
go, "Well, we're going to like totally cowtow the things Donald
Trump wants personally and hope that we get favors from the government,
right? Even if there's nothing explicit going on there, obviously
if they keep rewarding people who just follow the they do, who
follow the [__] they want, then there's there's some
like implicit agreement that is changing behavior that's allowing
like insanely corrupt [__] to happen." Like, that's
that's the problem right now. Based on a lot of my conversations
with people around chorus, I don't know if they'll I don't know
if I'll be able to convince any of those people because they
seem to think that you can't set up a positive incentive instruct
uh a positive incentive structure to change behavior. They think,
oh, no, no, no. You have to actually have explicit like negative
reinforcement, negative consequences for people to to change
behavior, right? Well, actually, I I don't think Trump ever said
like, "No, no, no, you you can have people who who like Charlie
Kirk." I don't know. I don't know if he ever explicitly said
like, "We'll punish you in some way." Okay. I don't know if he
put that in any any language or anywhere legal. It's like, no,
he he's obviously helping out and and favoring companies that
do what he wants, right? That's why every CEO is lining up to
suck his dick and do whatever the [__] he wants on
anything. It's why Zuckerberg's on his hip all the time. It's
why Bezos is on his hip all the time, right? He openly says it
even if he says it. It's not like a legal thing. It's not like
legally enforceable. He could take these privileges away at any
time. Why do people think corporations will save them from fascism?
Because for a while during the like 2016, 2015 to like 2022,
maybe 2023 even, those corporations were pretending they were
on your side. They were pretending, oh, this this orange man's
really bad. We hate him. We hate him. We hate him. And then the
orange man got power again. They're like, oh, actually, sir,
is that is that enough pressure on the tip, sir? Is that enough
pressure on the tip? Can you come like that, sir? >> It's
more against political opposition, or do you think it's kind
of going to stop once the Democrat takes power, or do you think
the Democrats are going to do it to Republicans? >> The
problem is, if you ask Republicans like, "What is your red line?"
and they'll never give you one. Republicans have no red line.
They will cheer for literally anything this administration does.
And I think Trump is realizing that more and more. So, you know,
where does it stop? I have absolutely no idea. I don't think
anybody knows where it'll stop. It'll stop wherever Donald Trump
wants it to stop, basically. >> All right. And, uh, I guess
one more thing I wanted to ask. So, uh, going back to I mean,
you've been deplatformed. Uh, do you have an urge to get back
on these sites that you've been banned from or do you just kind
of feel like you're carving your own lane now? >> Which
I mean, it'd be nice to, but I'm not holding my breath for it
right now. So yeah, just operate where you can, I >> I
think he's aware at this point that he's demonetized on YouTube.
Is I think he's This isn't From what I recall, this is not actually
the first time he's been demonetized on YouTube. I'm pretty confident.
I think I think there have been other times like this where he's
been demonetized. Maybe not like on the main channel. I'm trying
to remember he is. He said it it before people came up that oh
it's happened before. It's been appealed before. Like I think
August has told me about how he's appealed stuff. I don't think
it's happened on the main channel though where like all of his
streaming subscriptions are all of like the Destiny memberships
are. I think it's happened on like last night on Destiny before.
>> All right, cool. I just wanted to have a discussion
about that. So cool.
>> You're coward, Destiny. >> Oh, dog. What's up,
dude? >> I did not come here tonight to argue with you
nor anybody in this room. All I want to say is Jesus is king.
Jesus is Lord. Give your life to Jesus and you will never be
the same. Last thing I want to say is free Israel, Emnell high.
>> Hail Satan.
>> Wait, what? >> Last thing I want to say is free
Israel, Emil High. >> Hail Satan.
>> Why do you hail Satan? Somebody yells there. I don't
know. I don't know what she means. Free Israel there either.
I actually don't know. Did she Was that Yiddish?
What the [__] was the language afterwards? Free Israel.
Amnesh.
What was the was that? >> Another thing to say, right?
You have an actual thing to say.
>> Hey there. Uh, so, um, as one of the last speakers tonight,
I just want to say thank you for coming out. And I know that,
you know, you wouldn't condemn uh Charlie or Charlie Kirk's murder
without >> I'm Yel Kai. Okay, that I'm Israel Kai saying.
I don't know what that >> Trump doing. So, did I kind of
get that >> So, I immediately think of Cathol again when
I hear of this when I hear this guy. Okay. Psycho motor. Had
never heard of that concept before. This guy sounds like he's
got some psycho motor. Do we get this guy some SRI stat? SSRI
stat? Because Jesus Christ. >> Can you repeat that last
thing >> that you wouldn't condemn Charlie Kirk's murder
unless Donald Trump did so? >> I mean, like I condemn all
political violence. I will, but I don't want to go on I don't
want to go on shows where there are a bunch of Republicans that
deny anything happened on their side just to play the game on
the liberal side and then, you know, have the cycle repeat at
infinitum, which is where we're at over and over and over again.
Like, I think everybody should be willing to say >> that
make that totally makes sense. Um,
>> No, it doesn't. But Jesus
>> guys, I'm really I I hate this cycle. Okay. Okay. I
hate So, I'm going to break the What would this be like? Oh,
I can't. There's like There would be an analogy here, but it's
like I'm going to break the cycle by like saying something that
just makes things worse. I'm just going to opt for like the the
the less efficient play. I'm going to I'm just going to make
things worse. Okay, guys. You know what? I'm going to try a new
opening. Okay, I'm going to try this new opening in Starcraft
where I just highlight all of my drones and a click my base.
I think I'm I'm just going to try it. Okay, I you know, mining,
building a building a spawning pool, building a second expansion.
Okay, that that's that I don't know how well that's been working.
Okay, we just keep playing Starcraft games over and over. I'm
just going to target my own my own main base, my my first hatchery
with all my drones. I'm going to see what happens. >> Yeah,
as would I I would condemn his murder, Charlie Kirk's murder,
too, regardless of what the president did did or didn't do. And
I want to connect a uh a thread earlier about Republicans who
aren't afraid of political violence.
>> Zuckerberg, I have to be honest. This isn't cutting
it. If you don't increase the pressure to my tip, it will be
my fourth term before I come. >> Okay. Thank you, Mr. Trump,
for the >> Made the claims Islam is the sword of the left
>> is the sword the left is using to slit the throat of
America and that the left and Islam are two threats combining
forces to come after us. The migrants from Haiti will be raping
your women and hunting you down at night and will be coming for
your daughter next. These are things all things that Charlie
Kirk
>> Bro, that's actually the worst quot Kirk quote I've
ever heard.
Wait, did he really say that? Somebody find me that quote. What
the? That's way worse than the other stuff I've seen. also said
donors have been the number one funding mechanism of radical
open border neoliberal quasy Marxist policies cultural institutions
and nonprofits.
So you know he says all these things and people who aren't hateful
don't say things like that. The only next step for someone rational
who hears those things would be to try to the people who say
those things because
you know just operating under the pretense that um >> yeah
I understand what you're saying there. I mean I would be careful
with that obviously cuz you don't want to say that like you should
this gets us into like the punching up thing right
the big conversation that like people need to have is like if
you characterize your political opponents a certain way you're
basically only giving people violence a way out whether it's
dealing with you or dealing with your political opponents. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. I think that's a bad I think that the left has
had issues with that broadly for sure, but the right has a huge
issue with it right now that I won't address. But yeah, I mean
when you cast your enemies, you know, it's like good and evil
or it's the entirety of a party that is, you know, corrupted
or it's all immigrants or whatever. Like, yeah, that's it's
>> it just sucks that they're leaving people only one way
out. They're leading them to, you know, one conclusion. And uh
so you know I condemn his murder and I you know
uh and I condemn the shooter who killed him but it's like you
know
I am of the belief that people shouldn't be like he was that
the rhetoric has to be above that.
>> Yeah. I mean I mean I would agree obviously. Yeah. >> Yeah.
And um
>> sorry. What do you think it would take for folks to
real
>> the relief on Destiny's face when he counters a fellow
rationalist?
>> Dude, it's
>> Oh, what? What? >> Kirk's rhetoric and similar
rhetoric won't solve our problems.
>> Not true. >> Um I I have I have maybe more time
going forth where our problems aren't being
>> We're about to see with this terrorist stuff. So yeah,
I don't know. I guess we'll see you. >> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you. >> Thanks. Appreciate the fear and
your >> Yeah. Thanks a lot. >> I have a question
for you. >> Yeah. What's up? >> Hi, friend. So, recently
you have been uh I'm going to take the soy pill as well. Um as
somebody we've been friends for 3 years and support you in a
lot of ways, but I've been frustrated
by your peers performance and particularly the like leaning into
the ratcheting things up. Um, I agree that uh you won't you don't
want to clap for me. I can assure you I'm not we're not on the
same team. I agree that when there's two people stand >> um
if you got if you Destiny haters could not clap for me, I love
this person. Okay, I would do anything for this person. Don't
clap for me. You're not going to like >> standing with
lit matches and one person puts out the match. The issue is that
it doesn't stop the paper from burning if the other team won't
turn it out. And I agree that right now President Trump is refusing
to put that match out and most Republican pundits are refusing
to put that match out which I think is bad. Right. I I denounce
that behavior. I think it's harmful to the nation. The issue
is that when you're talking through the rationale for why we
need to >> Oh no. Is
Aronite has to take her normal position of like it's bad. What
do you want me to say? Okay. Where like you affect no change.
You just let the bad behavior continue. There's no changes whatsoever.
And Desi's arguing for the other side. probably way too hard
for the other side. Okay.
But how is Arrodite going to copy Destiny and think that bad
action from somebody else requires a change on your part? I don't
know. >> You typically use prisoners dilemma. >> Tough
needle. >> Tough needle. >> My issue with using like
game theory is that that's not how people work. I think that
when we try to assume like game theory or prisoners dilemma to
try to understand how people think and work, we're like assuming
that most people will continue to consistently act most rationally
and that the most rational outcome will be the thing that people
experience. And that's not really true. Like in the case of the
prisoner's dilemma, what you actually have is two sides where
the win condition isn't they e both get to get off scot-free
or they're one person's in jail, one person's not. The actual
issue is that it is an audience watching this and they get to
decide the outcomes of these people, right? If the left and right
are in a boxing match, the winning team isn't the team that gets
knocks the other team out faster or harder. It's who the audience
loves the most because that's how democracy works. And so a lot
of my issue with your like leaning into rationing up feels like
it's betraying the like fundamental psychology of how humans
work. >> Wait, it's like game theory doesn't apply to this
situation at all. It's like that's a totally
It's a totally self-s serving way of ever looking at this. Wow.
No way. If only other people had said that, >> which is
that it is not. >> No. No. Kyla. Kyla. Don't you know about
tit for tat, Kyla? Come on. >> Not the most rational thing.
Most moderates look at the assassination and they're horrified.
But then they look at you mocking Erica Kirk and they're horrified.
And the issue is that all we're doing is we're just driving normal
people further away. Not because they're making the most rational
decision, but because they are the audience that gets to decide
the winner.
And I'm terrified that you are driving the audience to look at
us as the villains. And I don't want the left to be the villains.
>> Yeah. So, I think that the
>> uh she is saying the correct thing. Yeah. She shouldn't
say I'm terrified. She should say what she actually thinks. She's
she what she's actually terrified of is telling Destiny her true
thoughts which are, hey, you are extremely harmful and I'm worried
that this gamble I took standing behind you is not going to pay
off. I think I'm going to have to walk away from you because
you are actually hurting everything I like want to stand for,
everything I pretend to stand for, you're hurting all of it and
you're making me look really bad. Okay, that's that's what she
actually wants to say. What she's going to say is I'm scared
that you are making us look bad. Wow. I think that when you look
at prisoners dilemma stuff or tit fortat strategies, I think
that's exactly how humans work. I think it maps on perfectly
to human behavior. I think that people don't do things that they
think there's going to be a bad outcome for it. I think that
people do do things that they feel like there's going to be some
cooperative effort for it. Um I I think that the the thing that
I guess I would fight for right now rather than just the um you
know whether or not you look on hint or not is I would just I
would I think there should be a fight for the framing. I think
that in a system where Donald Trump can make violent statement
after violent statement after violent statement after violent
statement if somebody could look at a random person on the left
and go, "Wow, this is too much for me." That system is deeply
broken and I think it's worth having the fight there rather than
to constantly play into the right-wing >> I I would grant
you this. The issue is
>> uh but here's the here's the issue. Okay, Destiny unilaterally
decides this is where the whole left has to fight this issue.
And now he's like the the left is full of because they won't
all back me up. Turn their back on their own morals when I didn't
ask. You won't back me up like totally in a totally cultlike
fashion like Donald Trump's cult does. Well, you guys are you
guys are actually I'm going to retire. That's the choice he's
given everyone else, right? Do you think he like thinks about
this? Do you think there's like any any sort of internal
I don't know internal critique that goes on? That's what he that's
a the choice he gave everybody else. And the funny thing is
is some people like Vosch for example, I think Vosch is ready
to go. He's like, "You know what? I know you totally threw me
under the bus when I made the same point, but it destiny's right
here." Right? Some people will do that, but most people won't.
And you don't get to make that decision for everybody else. And
they're not just because they don't want to they don't want to
die on the same hill you do, right?
This is like one of the least efficient hills to die on, too.
Have you heard of principles, JTO? Yes. Have you? You're a DJer.
Obviously not. Explain to me the principle that is at play here
where Destiny totally obliterated Vosch for having this same
take like two years ago and now he's totally changed his mind.
He's like, "Oh, me and V, we're on the same team. We're 100%
on the same side." You know who has principles? Vos. That's who
has the principles. Actually, Destiny's the one without them.
>> When I watched the Piers debate, you have Andrew Wilson.
The major attack that you had on him was denouncing Hortman and
he just immediately did it. And so all of a sudden you've lost
all the moral high ground. >> Oh, that is uh that was brutal
for him. Do you denounce the people who killed those DNC lawmakers?
Yeah, I do. Destiny.
Yeah, Destiny, I do. I trying to do the Andrew voice. Yeah, Destiny,
I do. I do disavow that Destiny. That's I I think that's kind
of how he
>> Well, to be clear, it's not losing any moral high ground.
It's losing your perceived optical high ground. But you know,
somebody who did the beginning on your statements were Jimmy
Kimmel. And >> that is true, Kilo. that Andrew will just
Andrew Andrew's brain works as like how do I win the argument.
It's not really like how do I how do I hold the morals all the
time unless he's got the the logic trees like the the dialogue
trees mapped out. It's just like how do I win the argument right
now? >> He just got completely suspended by the
on the right cheer it on. He didn't say anything on whatsoever.
So >> this this isn't selling to me, right? Like we we
agree on this. Jimmy Kimmel getting cancelled is stupid and everyone
participating in cancel culture is stupid. Like we agree on these
things. The issue is that to most normal viewers, they watched
you look more awful than ever. >> Except for Hassan. Hassan
is bad. Hassan's got to be cancelceled. Hassan's got to be deplatformed,
guys. Okay. Except for Hassan. All right. The platforming is
bad. Except for Hassan. >> Every other person on that panel,
whereas you could have just had the high ground if you go, of
course the of Charlie Kirk was wrong.
>> Of course. Why didn't you change it, >> Of course.
>> But why isn't the president calling down viol like
Twitter account? You guys always have fantasies in your mind
about what the conversation will look like next, but it never
ever ever goes that way. Like I can ask for example of it happening
and there's none. You have none. If you disavow it and you say,
"Yeah, of course it's about it." But what about this person on
Twitter? Anna Casparian on that program disavowed it and Andrew
Wilson started bringing up old tweets of hers and then when he
didn't know he had old tweets of started bringing up old tweets
of jank and then he started bringing up old tweets from the Young
Turks and Ana Caspar wasn't any closer than I was to having any
kind of like >> but now you can immediately move that conversation
into a more interesting conversation. It's not more interesting
to find out why violence is the same thing as being mean and
that's a meaningful conversation to have. >> I I clearly
not because I'm not I've never incited violence against Erica.
You just said it looks bad to you know say anything about the
fact that she's fundraising for Charlie Kirk, you know, on her
husband's death, which I think is crazy in the immediate aftermath
of that. So I I mean I would rather have I mean I don't know.
We'll see. I guess in a year or two how it pans out. But >> in
today's episode of Kylo Tries to teach Destiny how to be a human
being, we watch him be totally alien and and incapable of any
empathy at all. By the way, it's totally normal for Erica Kirk
to do the fundraising for Charlie and it's totally normal for
everybody to go see. They're just back to normal. They're back
to business as usual. It's like politics, okay? You're like playing
a game and there was like a timeout and the other side went time
in and they started playing with the ball and then when you went
to go play soccer again when you went to go play, they're like,
"Wait, wait, wait. Charlie died. Why are you playing right now?"
No, you don't get to continue on with the game and tell the other
side, "No, no, no. Don't play anymore." No, we're in timeout
still. You're not in timeout. You're literally kicking the ball
down the field. [__] you talking about? >> I
think I'd rather have the argument over like the framing needs
to change that it can't constantly be that one side has to act,
you know, 50 million levels of morality above the other side
to be taken seriously. That's just that's just a very unserious
and if if that is where the moderator is at or the norm is at,
then I guess we just go to the next whatever the next form of
government is after that the current one is not working. Yeah.
>> Hi Stephen. Uh
>> hey guys.
>> That sounds like Zip Zip. Okay. I don't know if Zip
Zip went there, but we thought the other guy earlier people were
joking. He drove from Florida here. That just sounded like Zip
Zip.
>> Hi, Stephen. >> Hey, guys.
>> Can we just have
>> uh my question is, what is something that you think
that we all could do, yourself included, to promote unity in
politics, in the culture, just unity? What do you
>> That's I'm telling you, I heard it and I'm like, that's
that's definitely Zip Zip, right? He's got the notebook. That's
the notebook. That's the notebook from the Pixie trial. I It
sounds like him. It sounds like him, but uh hard to say. What
did Marty Epste say here? The view of human beings being purely
utility maxing automatons was created
was created
to inform descriptive academic approaches like decision theory
and market design/economic economics. Econ economists will constantly
will constantly undergrads in econ 101 or teach undergrads in
econ 101 to never jump to normative conclusions from game/decision
theory. But because Destiny's a simpleton low IQ something something,
he can't grasp anything requiring any thought beyond a recursive
non-contingent process as encapsulating all human behavior. Yeah.
Okay. I get like Yeah. I think game theory is obviously too simplistic.
it. I'd say when you get enough people and and you get like randomized
behavior, I would say game theory almost certainly can't work
with politics, but like buying and selling like I do think out
of like random behavior, game theory could start to make some
sense. Could be useful for an uh analyzing situations and it
could be useful just to inform your decisions, right, on like
what you think the opponent's most optimal moves are, but it's
like yeah, in terms of informing like average citizen behavior
or like political behavior, I don't see why it would be good,
right? And I think the the other thing that you have to remember
with like uh like the prisoner's dilemma is you have like an
incredibly incredibly limited action set with the prisoners dilemma.
That's not how real life works, right? That's not at all how
real life works. And trying to model human behavior off of the
prisoners's dilemma or say that this is a prisoner's dilemma,
it's stupid. There's a million different decisions people could
do other than oh, I have to I have to listen, I'm waiting. Either
they all disavow violence or we don't. That's that's not how
any of this
>> You think would help? I think one of the most corrosive
aspects to conversation is when people assume the other person
is operating in bad faith. That when somebody says they want
the whole country to be religious, it's just because they want
to be oppressive and, you know, shut down everybody's religions
rather than they genuinely think that Jesus Christ is the only
way through salvation and that it'll make everybody's life better.
Um, and then on the same when people are fighting for, you know,
trans healthcare, you know, other people thinking, oh, they just
want to brainwash my kid and, you know, you know, chop their
genitals off or whatever. Um, I think that the most important
thing you can do if you're trying to find common ground, you're
going to try to win a debate or own somebody, you know, or screaming
somebody on a college campus. I think the best thing you can
do is assume the other person is coming at it in good faith and
then try to figure out like why do you think this would make
the country better when I think something completely different
would make the country better. Um, I think that would be one
of the most important things. But I think our whole media apparatus
is driven towards kind of like rage, baiting, and outrage and
everything. >> I completely agree. Um, wow. And I know
it's hard because people come at you really in a already turned
up to 11, but I mean uh would you be more would you be able to
say that going forward you're going to try and assume that some
of these Trump supporters do approach it from good faith? Maybe
not the ones that are come at you screaming full volume, but
the ones like um I don't know if she's still in here, but the
girl with >> Yeah, I don't think that's zip zip. Okay,
I'm I'm pulling it back. I don't think that's >> the hat
and she she had a really like you know it ended with I I agree.
It ended with her saying I agree with you. So I think um >> same
voice. >> Yeah. So like this sounds kind of sick. I don't
mean to sound that way. I think that most of the people in places
like this I think are good faith, but that's the reason why like
I have so much anger for some of the larger conservative figures
I debate because I think that they don't do it in good faith
and I think they're misleading a lot of >> Hold on. What
if I told you that Steven regularly says that Kyla or not so
ord is really good at debate and does a really good job. >> Does
a really good job.
Sorry, I think back to the clip. Thank you. Uh let's see. Zip
Zip was in the back looking for unattended shoes to steal. That's
actually more likely there, Kathy. That's that's almost certainly
true. Okay. And I wanted to look at this. This is the most This
is the most delusional comment. Okay, I feel like I should probably
time you out so we don't just farm you and make fun of you all
for the rest of the time you're here. But uh Drama 101 says,
"Jay talk. It would be actually funny if Trump comes out and
condemns it because of destiny." Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
I just I feel bad. Wait, what the Why is my Hold on. What? Why
is my my thing isn't working? My social stream highlight isn't
working. What the heck? Wait, what? What the heck's going on?
The highlight isn't working. Okay. Well, whatever. Intentionally
figured out. Um, you know, there was we argued about Jan 6 earlier
in here and about, you know, people being led into the building.
When I debated Owen Shroyer on stage, I bet him $5,000 that the
people that broke into the capital were broad boys first and
he wouldn't take that bet with me on stage. And the reason why
is cuz he knew that he was lying. But I bet there are people
in the audience that would take a smaller bet because they're
really confident because he sells that lie to him. So, yeah,
that it's something that bothers me a ton. I think that I mean
my my mom and dad are both hardcore MAGA, so I don't think they're
bad faith. I don't think they want to be destroyed. Um, yeah,
I think that most people on the ground, most people that are
listening to media and, you know, even that aren't absorbed in
it 24/7 are coming at it, you know, with some level of good faith.
So, it's it's the pundits that that drive me the craziest. Yeah.
>> I agree. Thank you. >> Just can I bring it out?
>> Yeah. Okay. You got anything left you want to say? >> Um,
you guys, [__] Benjamin Netanyahu,
>> [__] Benjamin Netanyahu.
[__] this power that comes up here and wishes for
violence on citizens. >> All right, guys. >> Does
not support
or debate. This is a
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> That's one thing we can all agree on that we want this
guy out. MAGA or not. >> I like one thing I mean I will
say and I hope that like I hope that people on the right keep
this in mind too. Like I do think we have something really special
in the United States where we can all get around and shadow people.
And I appreciate Listen, man. Even you, you know, God bless you.
That's great. You know, the next day I suck, I'm going to have
you in mind when I do. Listen, I I do think it's nice.
You know, the guys that are screaming at me over here, hey, I
appreciate it. You came out and shouted at me. >> Uh, drama
101. The the thing where you said, "What if Trump comes out and
disavows because of Destiny?" Trust me, Queen and I on the same
page there, okay? You don't have kids. Just don't have kids.
Okay? We're on the same page on that one. I promise you, I don't
even need to ask him a question. We got the the [__]
Jew connection right now. Now I've got the mind meld happening.
We don't need to share any thoughts on that. We both see it the
same way. All right. It was an insane premise. >> You didn't
shoot me. I appreciate it. This guy out here, you know, God bless
him. I hope your dog and your family that was here recording
you, you know, God bless you, too. So, I do appreciate it. I
appreciate it. Thank you so much.
>> All right, guys. We're wrapping up here.
>> Okay. Thank you. >> Sees you as an embarrassment.
>> All right, guys. Thank you so much for coming. Please
visit our website.
>> That is true. you can donate, sign up. >> Rob
Nor going crazy. Well, I believe Rob's probably going crazy here.
If I had to guess, Rob Nor is probably going crazy because I
think he basically got told like I actually don't stand behind
anything Destiny's saying. I'm actually not I'm not down with
anything he's been saying. And then Erdite's here like literally
holding the microphone. She's literally being the mic stand for
Destiny's Q&A session. That's that's her role right now.
She is the mic stand for Destiny's Q&A session.
And Rob's probably sitting there like, "Wait, didn't you tell
me that you weren't a part of this? That you didn't have anything
that like it was weird for me to hold you accountable for these
things?" Rob's probably feeling a little gas lit if I had to
get >> to volunteer and you could start a campus chapter.
Thank you guys.
>> Yeah, sure. Hold on. My thing is still on. Hold on.
>> Okay. We've got we got a couple other related things
to go through here before we finish off with all this content.
I think there was a a doobie appearance. Okay. I I was told I
I've heard tell of a doobie appearance on Wick TV that we should
maybe check out. All right. I've heard tell of such a thing.
I might I might pull up a clip here in just a second. We've got
this We've got this doobie appearance. And then what else is
there? What is this? Okay. Can we Can we Can we not Can we not
I don't know what that I don't know what that's a reference to.
I don't know what that could possibly be a reference to. I don't
know. What is that? I you guys are being weird. A lot of weird
people in chat right now. I don't know what's going on with that.
I don't know what that is. Hold on. Let me pull it. Let me pull
it back. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> [__]
Benjamin. >> What does it mean? >> Hold on. Are you
still watching the stream? Nothing. >> You can't even see
the moon.
>> Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. It's fine.
If you guys can't hear, Cherry's asking me uh what what I'm talking
about. What I mean? She says she can't even see the moon. Uh,
we're trying to, by the way, guys, I need to set up like some
XLR stuff to do. We're We're trying to Oh, they do hear you.
Okay. We're trying to what do you call it? We're trying to set
up audio in the same room. I don't know if anyone has any experience
with that. I might have some questions. I just want to know who
I should ask questions to like tomorrow if I need to ask questions.
So, send me a message on Discord if you got an idea of what's
going on with like audio like that to set up basically two microphones
in the same room that either cancel things out or are directional.
Anyway, we're uh we're good. We're good on this. I think we're
going to have two directional mics. I think it's not going to
be a problem.
>> Okay. Yes. Yes. That's what it was. Yep. Yep. That's
what it is. That is what it is. Sure. I got it. >> What's
up? >> It hit eventually.
Okay. We got a We got a Doobie time stamp here. Okay. Doobie
hopped on to Wick TV. I think this is about free speech. Something
to do with Destiny. I saw another clip from this of Wick basically
getting mad that people were like, "Wait, didn't you support
Hassan getting deplatformed?
Why would this be >> Oh. Um,
so I just really quick, right? >> Oh, the clip is just
for a time stamp, guys. Don't worry. >> So, so I agree
with you almost entirely. Probably entirely actually. Um, I just
got to say really quickly, um, because there are some people
who are saying the stuff about the president has not called has
actually called for violence and hasn't called for nonviolence
like the last guy that you just had on. And that's just not true.
Um after Charlie Kirk was shot um he even he said something like
uh Charlie was all about speaking whatever the and he wants to
see people respond with nonviolence because that's what Charlie
would want. So he said that explicitly, right? And then Destiny
on I mean Alexander Win made this point that um the first time
uh that Destiny big on Piers Morgan was the first time um people
said or people saw um like that Trump had not called for nonviolence
and he'd been actually like been inflaming violence or whatever
the or but that's also not true because Destiny son of Piers
Morgan that Trump um said that he doesn't care about uniting
the country or he doesn't care about white rightwing violence
and which is total I mean, you can watch the Fox 2 News interview
what he actually said um when asked the question about uh how
to unite the country basically. >> Wait, hold on.
Did Did Trump say basically the same thing? No, sorry. The thing
we were advocating for, was Trump like borderline like I disavow
all violence, but just so you know, it's like the far left. They're
way worse. Did he Did he do that? Am I Am I
>> Wait, what did he say? you know, something like, uh,
I'm going to say something's going to get me in trouble, but
I couldn't care less. And then he goes on to give his actual
answer, right? What he's saying is he doesn't he he couldn't
care less about getting in trouble. His his actual answer was
uh he thinks that right-wing violence is caused by um anger about
immigration, criminality,
uh jobs, etc. Right? And he thinks his policy is fixing those
things. He thinks leftwing violence is caused by their push for
like trans rights or whatever the and and that's why he thinks
that's a problem. Now I don't agree with Trump to be clear but
he did not say he doesn't care about unit in the country. He
did not call for violence. He did not say he doesn't care about
right-wing violence. >> We can agree at least that Trump
is doing a very poor job at turning down the temperature. I saw
his address on the the after the Kirk shooting where he had like
five minute address. >> Wait, who the [__]
who the [__] pinned this chat from Kilo? What the
>> I think we watched it on >> him there. >> The
first half was fine, but the last half was kind of unhinged,
right? It was it was definitely not what he needed to say and
do in that moment. Can we agree on that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. So, so I think that um and but
I think this would be expected from like any president, any political
figure. I think it I think it's reasonable to assume that this
shooter was a leftwing person >> probably at this point
>> and given that given that he knew Charlie Kirk personally,
right? I I think it it's you can expect the guy to be a little
upset. >> But remember, hold on. Remember at the at the
day of we had no information about the shooter, right? We had
nothing on him, right? >> Yeah, of course. But I mean,
I think I think you can >> and that's when he was making
his >> I think it's a safe assumption, I think, to make.
And I >> Yeah, I got my I got my highlight back. Okay,
it's good. >> I think it's irresponsible. I think he's
extremely irresponsible for doing it as a [__] president.
But I think most people expected it was probably some like leftwing
person, right? Um, I I I think most people probably didn't think
it was like a a right-wing Christian guy, right? But but to be
clear, I agree that it was irresponsible for him to do. I think
that he can do much more to bring down the the rhetoric. Um,
and I think that the right needs to confront the fact that their
rhetoric is is a massive driver of this problem, right? And it
has been for a long time. But >> okay, this is going to
upset somebody, right? This is going to upset a ton of people.
Um, actually Trump did kind of say that violence is bad. I I
guarantee there's going to be somebody's like,
>> did you just say that Trump's not the >> I think
the left has some some blame there too, right? I think both sides
just need to bring it down. Um, if you want to see like uh like
how somebody and maybe you could do this for your audience at
some point, right? Because you have this idea that the way that
Destiny's doing it is only that it can be done. >> Uh,
Medi Hassan did a uh an interview um with uh on Newsweek. I think
it was Newsweek or Newsmax with um Chris Cuomo and he has some
other guests on that was like a Republican dude and he made the
exact point that Destiny's been making, right? um which is that
the Republicans have been pushing the violence. They're the ones
committing most of the violence that Trump is rhetoric and his
his actions actually have been the things that are infling people.
Um and you can do that like he did in that that interview without
sounding like the arranged like sociopath, right? Like there's
no reason to go that that far or so that might be a good thing
for you to watch at some point or
link it to me and I'll give it a view. >> Hold on. I'm
saying for the actual content.
Oh, there you go. >> There. Uh Matt's going to come in
and just totally spur. All right. Maybe she can tell us a little
bit about how like not even trial can take Destiny down. >> Okay,
Mantis, now's your chance. Now's >> By the way, everybody
who brings this person on with that content with that comment
existing, okay? Like to support your points. I just I wouldn't
want that person near my like political movement personally,
but hey.
>> It's fine. >> You're muted on your end now. >> Yes,
you brought me on. Sick. I did not think you would. >> Why
didn't you think I This is going to be content, baby. Why would
I Why would I Why wouldn't I bring you on?
Go ahead. >> I just went I was just in chat
like five minutes before my next segment. So, you >> Okay.
Okay. Well, I was just in chat going at Doobie about like this
like
weasly little like way of saying I I feel like Doobie is again
underplaying the way that Trump speaks where Trump says about
90% of the is divisive, inflammatory, uh like not unifying at
all. But because he said this one sentence, like he thinks he's
he's like running around saying, "Oh my god, I can't believe
people are lying about what Trump said." Like what the he obviously
every sentiment in all of his speech bar one sentence is divisive.
No. >> Divisive in what way? >> I I I I think you're
fainting ignorance, which is really cringy. >> If it's
easy if it's easy, just answer the [__] question.
>> What do you mean? It's it's obvious in every way. In
every way.
>> That's why just the question >> I'm answering,
but I'd like to say you're fanny ignorance because you're a piece
of [__] But okay, I'll answer. Go for it. >> I
just explained in chat how after he said the thing that you said
when he said I don't really care, right? You said when he said
I don't really care, he wasn't saying I don't really care about
not unifying the country. You're correct. I agree with you. It's
not the relevant part though because immediately after that he
went on to explain how when the right does violence, it's justified
and when the left does it. >> He didn't say that. >> No,
this is what I mean. So you're like [__] delusional.
He didn't say when the right does violence is justified. He said
he was saying the whole to be clear. Do you think that do you
think that he said when the when the right does violence is justified?
Do you think those words can when the right does to violence
they do it because they want less crime? That's the thing he
said. So now that it's justified now that it's justified only
only that he thinks this is where their anger comes from. This
is where the anger comes from that leads them to to commit violence.
And then he goes on to explain that he thinks his policies have
dealt with those issues. Right. So he which to me I think any
reasonable person
would imply
>> Hold on. Hold on. You're both talking. You're both >> We
should just get the clip >> talking at once and I can can't
hear either of you. Do we finish and then Mantis can respond
uninterrupted? Okay. Do we finish your point? Then Mantis, go
>> Okay. So, he gives the reasons like the the causes of
like what he thinks are the causes of right-wing violence, right?
And then he goes on to explain how he thinks his policies have
fixed those things, right? And he's fixed the country, right?
So, to me, I think any reasonable person, this implies that he
thinks that the issue of right-wing violence or the issues causing
right right-wing violence are dealt with, so there'll be less
rightwing violence. Then he goes on to explain where he thinks
leftwing violence comes comes from which is like people want
trans or whatever the right ones make everybody trans. Um and
then he so then he says that's the issue because his policies
are not addressing those things. His policies are doing the opposite
of addressing those things. So to be clear I don't agree with
him but he doesn't say that he doesn't care about right violence.
He doesn't say it's justified. He doesn't say anything like that.
>> So again you're ignoring like you're acting like when
people sit and listen to this that they they're able to like
decipher everything. We know that most voters most people most
people >> uh he definitely did this latigious gamer. Like
I definitely remember this at minimum, right? Where it's like
when the right when the right is uh when the right's upset about
stuff that makes sense. When the left upset the left is just
crazy. They're just they're just evil. They just hate America.
Actually >> watch anything political are just bot. Okay.
So they listen to stuff. They hear a sentiment. They get a vibe
and then they move. >> Oh, no way.
Dude, dude, hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
Most of the people who watch who engage in politics are just
bot. Okay. Okay, they're just bot. Not Not We won. Not even could
get rid of my guy. We won, guys. We won. Most people who watch
politics are just bots.
Uh my my political streamer can can consume. You can't even stop
him. Losers. You're bots. You're all bots.
Amazing.
>> To be fair, that's a that's a crazy tweet. That's a
funny tweet that I reference all the time. So maybe Mantis actually
won in the end. >> Move on with their day. And when Trump
is sitting in front of everybody and he says when the right-wing
does violence, when the far right does violence, they do it because
they want less crime. And then when the left wing does less violence,
they do it because they're of trans people or because they're
[__] insane. Essentially, like everybody understands
that the VIP is giving across is that the right wing is not that
bad. And the >> Wait, I just I just figured something out.
Hold on. Hold on. They didn't prosecute Epstein or like anybody
affiliated with that. Is it all just politics?
I feel like it's all just politics. Listen, look.
The machine goes after Destiny just fine. Leftist, they go after
him perfectly fine. Right-wing is that why all of these like
tech billionaires who like this why all these tech billionaires
suddenly switch to being right-wing? They're like, "Oh, guys,
you know what? Mark Zuckerberg, Peter Teal, they're all just
like, you know what, guys? We actually we had to switch ideology.
We cannot get we cannot get prosecuted for this." I feel like
I'm seeing it. Okay. Leftwing very bad. rightwing. Um, listen,
white hat, same >> Left wing is their real problem. The
>> you read about the Epstein birthday book. I mean, a
little bit. Yeah, >> leftwing is worse. Those are not unifying
sentences. That is not a unifying message to to say immediately
after saying, I'm just I'm about to say something really like
cringe and I don't really care about like the consequence of
of it. And then you come up here and defend that. Like, and I
know that you're you then say, "Oh, I don't agree with what he
said. I don't agree with what he said." But I am going to defend
like what that he said it. Okay.
Listen, you [__] idiot. I hate you demonstrated.
Oh god. >> I I I do hate to do this, but I have an appointment
at 8:30. The Gibbs is going to be mad if I'm too late. I'll >> get
to suck my face. Okay, cool. Fun times. Fun times.
All right, what else do we have for today, guys? I got a couple
quick hits that I missed off the top. All right, couple quick
hits. Where are we going? We got Tucker. Tucker defending free
speech. Hope that >> Tucker standing on business. All right.
He's a little concerned that people might use Charlie Kirk's
death to enact some speech measures that people do not >> You
hope that Charlie Kirk's death won't be used by a group we now
call bad actors
to create a society that was the opposite of the one he worked
to build. You hope that you hope that a year from now the turmoil
we're seeing in the aftermath of his murder won't be leveraged
to bring hate speech laws to this country. And trust me, if it
is, if that does happen, there is never a more justified moment
for civil disobedience than that ever. And there never will be.
I actually didn't hear that part when I first watched. Okay,
Tucker's like, "Okay,
Tucker's having his Vosch moment." For Vosch, it was what he
thought was the transgenicide legislation. Okay, you're to take
my You're going to take my fanboys away, everybody to arms. Tucker's
like, "You're taking my away to arms." Everybody, people have
their own pet issues. Okay. Never will be there there be never
will there be a better excuse for civil disobedience that if
America passes hate speech >> because if they can tell
you what to say
they're telling you what to think. There is nothing they can
[__] because they don't tipped $3.
>> I can't believe Rick brought me on. I'm so grateful.
Do people really think I'm functionally [__] >> Uh
you're human. They don't believe you have a soul.
A human being with a soul, a free man has a right to say what
he believes. Not to hurt other people, but to express his views.
You hope that.
Wow. True. It's almost like speech can't be violence. But the
the only speech that can be violence is speech that pushes violence.
The speech that calls for violence. Okay.